Four three,
two,
one.
All right.
We live.
What's up man?
What's up dude?
What's hilarious folks?
I have to tell you this.
I did a podcast earlier today and he said,
wow,
it's your second for the day.
He goes,
impressive endurance.
Do you know how fucking
ridiculous that is for you to say,
this is a guy who walked
across an article.
How many days did it take you?
54 days by yourself.
By myself checking the
fucking frozen Tundra it,
that was an endurance feat of its own.
Yeah.
Just that's a real endurance feed.
I'm just sitting down talking to people.
Oh my God.
You talked already for two hours.
How do you do it?
Two more hours.
Here we go.
Yeah.
Yup,
Yup.
To what the fuck were you doing?
Just just getting back.
Actually.
Still,
uh,
still practically have
the snow on my shoes.
Yeah.
I got back about a month ago.
54 day journey.
First person in history to
cross the entire continent.
Solo unsupported.
So no resupplies throughout the thing.
No,
no aid,
no wind kites,
nothing.
Just me dragging a 375 pound
sled across Antarctica.
I can't believe it only took you 54 days.
Yeah,
it's so big.
When you look at an article on a map,
like how long do you think it would
take you to walk across America?
Well you got,
so we usually look at Antarctica
to map this hilarious.
I have show people a
picture of Antarctica.
You're a smart guy.
You probably noticed,
but usually people see it on a map
projection because then it gets flat.
Right?
It's actually circular.
Um,
so I went from the edge of the raw and
I shelf to the Ra via the south pole to
the Ross ice shelf.
So basically kind of a diagonal across,
through the center and then
back to the other ice shelf.
What do the flat earthers think about?
You are traversing this,
this area.
This is what you did.
This is how you,
there it is.
Exactly.
Yes.
We went to the center of
the fucking earth basically.
There it is.
The top of the pole yet
bottom of the earth,
you know,
standing down there holding
everyone up on my shoulders.
Wow.
So you were at the South Pole
and then you trucked over to the,
to the ice shelf in their side.
It's funny you say about the flat
earthers though because all jokes aside,
I be getting a lot of trolling on my
Instagram page from the flat earthers I've
got guys go,
I'm like,
oh I was doing this speech the other day.
People are Super Nice.
Come up in the Q and a afterwards
I want to shake my hand,
take a picture,
whatever.
And this guy walks up and this real
earnest look on his face and he's like,
so I really wanted to ask
you how was the whole?
And I was like,
excuse me.
He was like,
he know the hole at the
center and I was like,
ah,
I can give me a little more.
He was like,
you know like when you got to the edge
and I was like,
Oh man,
like you're really asking
this question right now.
Like we are talking about this.
I didn't quite know where to go with it.
I was like,
yeah,
there was actually,
I at least I didn't see the edge and the
curvature kept going and I made such a
strange thing to believe,
but people do it.
People think people are
trolling about that.
And you know what?
It actually started out,
it's another four Chan thing,
you know?
Did you know that it's,
well,
I'm sure there was probably somebody
who believed it before that,
but it started people trolling on
four Chan and then eventually
people just started actually going,
hey,
you input it is flat.
And then they started
believing it and videos,
youtube videos popped up.
There's another youtube video of
someone linked to me the other day and I
thought it had like,
I thought it had like a few hundred views.
We had 28,000 views.
There was all these guys debating like
call and prove that there's not a wall.
The wall,
like there would be like game of
Thrones at the edge of the world.
There's this whole conversation.
I bet there's another 28,000 people.
It's proved to call and
never actually weren't.
Oh,
he's a new world order shill.
Well,
the other,
the other buddy wide was that we
got up budge on the Instagram page.
I'm out there alone completely by myself,
but I wanted to share the whole story
through my Instagram to like share that
journey with people,
inspire others to do
whatever they want to do.
And it kept being like,
what mean he's not out there alone.
He's taking pictures.
Was like the film crew as like guys,
have you never heard of a tripod?
And if in a timer,
uh,
watched survivor man.
Exactly.
So it's so,
it's so funny.
Comments along those lines.
So your,
your sled was 300 and how many pounds?
375 pounds of start.
So basically,
uh,
food and fuel was the main,
the main way.
So people,
I called my project the impossible first.
That's sort of what I named the project
because several people would try it
right there.
So not only walking,
you're dragging this big ass heavy sled.
Yeah,
yeah.
And Dude,
people.
So people have tried this,
uh,
you know,
going back a hundred years to sh Ernest
Shackleton saying if it was possible.
And then the last few years,
some really experienced polar explorers
have given it a shot and one guy
actually died less than a hundred
miles from the finish shine.
Um,
because of lack of nutrition and some
challenges with the weather and things
like that.
Um,
but people called it,
you know,
people after that,
we're like,
it's impossible.
And the reason people thought it
was impossible because you can't get
resupplies,
meaning if you feel your sled
with food and a certain amount,
you actually can't drag this led anymore.
So the whole math equation really was
figuring out just how much food and fuel I
could put in the sled.
The fuel melts the water,
so melts the ice into water essentially,
and that equal to 375 pounds.
And to be truth,
I could barely pull it on the first day.
Like I a one hour into
getting dropped off.
I'm dropped off completely
alone out there in Antarctica.
I planned this project for a year,
you know,
uh,
and uh,
I get dropped off and after about one
hour pulling 375 pound sled through the
snow,
it's minus 25 degrees out.
I'm crying,
I'm literally crying and the tears
in my goggles are starting to freeze.
And I'm like,
oh my God.
So I pick up my satellite phone,
I call home to my wife Jenna,
who also creates and plans
all these projects with me.
And I'm like,
Babe,
uh,
I think we named the
project the right thing.
The impossible verse.
Yep.
It looks like it might be
impossible to keep going.
So I'm one hour into a
thousand mile journey.
Poetess sled told everyone I'm going
to do this and I'm already having those
doubts pull up.
Uh,
you know,
fortunately I was able to get a little
bit further that day and 54 days later
and made it to the end.
But how far did you get in the first day?
Well,
it's funny cause we show,
just show the map.
I actually,
you know,
it starts on the ice shelf,
which is basically the frozen sea
ice and there's an edge of that.
That's where the continent starts.
And so I have a waypoint
on my gps that marks that.
So the plane that drops me off actually
dropped me off on the ice shelf before
the continent starts.
And my first way point was
kind of like the actual start.
And so one hour in,
I haven't even hit the real start.
So when she,
when I call her on the phone,
she's like,
cause she knows the route.
And she was like,
well how far are you
from the first way point,
which is where the actual start.
And I'm like,
it's 0.63 more miles.
She's like,
it's half a mile.
You have a thousand more to go.
Like get to the first way point,
you know?
And I was like,
okay,
okay.
So I,
you know,
rallied myself,
got to the first way point and then
finally got in my tent that night and just
kind of took a deep breath.
I think I was just overwhelmed
by the magnitude of it.
I mean,
imagine being a speck in the
middle of Antarctica alone,
these crazy temperatures,
you know,
all the excitement but
fears of the journey ahead.
Um,
and 375 pounds on my back when the sleds,
when the snow's deep too
loose snow makes 375 pounds,
even even heavier than if it's like light,
you know,
icier consolidated.
So yeah,
it was,
it was a rough start to say the least.
Did you do any sort of test run
pulling the sled anywhere else?
Yeah,
so the training element
of it was pretty cool.
So,
um,
this was,
I actually said a few other world records
previous to this and the mountains and
things we could talk about if you want.
But the,
uh,
the last year I really
committed to this project,
I,
um,
yet decided to obviously start
training specifically for this.
Um,
I needed to put on about
20 pounds of muscle.
I'm usually six foot one 65.
Pretty Lean.
I'd race triathlon professionally for a
number of years and realized I needed to
be a bit bigger because I was
going to lose so much weight.
Um,
and I found an amazing coach in Portland,
Oregon where I live.
This guy named Mike McCastle.
I don't know if you've ever heard of him,
but I know you've had,
you've had David Goggins on your show.
I take it.
So,
um,
Mike actually surpassed
David's pullup record.
Mike did 5,804 pull ups in 20 hours.
Um,
I think Goggins at about 4,000,
which are both insane to me because
I can do like another thousand.
And he was,
Mike was wearing a 30 pound weight.
[inaudible]
yes.
Just to add insult to injury,
uh,
Mike McCastle absolute absolute legends.
So anyways,
a minute,
wait a minute.
5,000 fucking Chin ups
with a weight vest on,
dude that barely can do 10 love.
I'm right there with you
at like pull ups are not.
I've got some other physical strikes,
but the pullup department is not,
not my strong suit is fucking insane.
Get this too.
Just cause I got to,
I got a big up my band for a second.
That's his fourth world right here.
Also pulled a f two 50 truck,
20 miles across death valley.
Uh,
in a harness.
So I'm trying to look for the best guy
to teach me how to pull heavy Shang.
My God,
you got the guy,
I found the guy,
I was like,
fuck,
this is the guy out.
Does it just make you
feel like such a pussy?
And the greatest thing about Mike,
you know,
big,
strong jacked dude,
but like super soft spoken.
She's like,
he's like,
yeah,
I did this pope's.
So it was cool.
Like,
so anyways,
I basically
fucked with that record so hard he could
die and like come back to life and live
a whole nother live and no
one's ever going to do it.
Yeah.
So anyways,
my training,
he would,
he was the guy went to him train
out of this gym in Portland,
uh,
where,
where he trains out of and he just,
he got me bigger,
he got me stronger.
But he also did all sorts
of bad ass crazy stuff.
I mean there's a physical challenge,
but it's more of a mental
challenge in anything.
So he had me,
you know,
my hands in ice buckets,
doing planks to get my heart rate
jacked up and then he'd be like,
get out of the water.
Then I pulled my hands
out of the ice buckets.
Do you not be a seated
squat against the wall?
But then he would hand me Legos
and so my hands are frozen.
My feet are in ice buckets now in a plank.
My heart rates,
you know,
one 90 and he's like,
put this Lego set together.
So the deck dexterity in my fingers,
the mental acuity to
pull this all together.
There is this guy,
what a fucking savage this guy is.
He and he did that for veteran suicides.
Yeah,
exactly.
So he did,
he's got really,
really important missions
behind all of his projects.
He calls him 12 labors in over his life.
He's trying to set 12 route
world records and various things.
People that are just,
they're just designed different.
Yeah.
So he's the man.
But like this crazy
training he came up with,
for me that was like the ice,
the water,
the mental acuity.
All of this was like,
he was like,
Yo,
you're going to be in Antarctica
if your tent blows away,
when you're pulling it up,
you're dead.
Like the stakes are that high 50,
60 mile per hour winds
like absolutely crazy.
Um,
so should we ever have an issue like that
where you thought the could blow away?
Um,
I think,
I don't know if you have it.
There's a clip on my Instagram.
I posted a few days ago of me of me
setting up the tent in a minus 80 degrees
out,
60 mile per hour winds.
Um,
it's pretty gnarly,
but yeah,
I mean there was one time when the
10 almost did blow away from me yet.
There's this one,
there's one other one.
This is me getting into looking
like an absolute disaster.
What?
I get help with audio,
but that's me.
That's me.
Whoa.
You're pulling eyesight got caught on a
massive storm and I was just so hard to
get the tent up.
I didn't know if I was gonna be able to
get it up where I was going to have to
just keep walking.
Now,
hopefully these tent poles hold,
man,
that was really intense.
How do you stay warm in that tent?
So it average temperature
is about minus 25 minus 30.
Uh,
and Antarctica,
like I said,
when the wind jacks up,
uh,
I don't know if there's the other
cup of me setting up the tip,
but if you get a chance to see that it's,
you know,
it's about Kimmy about minus 80 outside,
which it's hard to wrap
your mind around that.
But I've tried to put it in perspective
by saying I could take a cup of boiling
water and throw it in an air
and immediately turns to ice.
Like that's,
that's,
that's the temperature would dealing with,
yeah.
This is me trying to,
uh,
keep the tent poles together.
Usually you have someone
else to hold onto it,
but I'm alone.
I'm completely alone out there.
So this is me struggling with my tent,
just trying to keep it up.
I've got it tied down to my sled.
They're just battling battling
the winds and the state.
Like I said,
the stakes are high.
If that blows away,
I don't have a spare 10.
I've got no extra weight in
my sled to hold spare stuff.
So it's,
it's,
it's do or die quite literally in a
moment like that have a patch kit.
I had a couple of things repaired,
his sewing kit,
a patch kit,
stuff like that.
But if the tent itself or the temples,
you know,
pretty much done.
And also you have to set up your tripod
and film and then press stop and go back
and send it.
How are you keeping these
batteries juiced up?
No,
this is,
this is the film crew man
that was following me around
that right of the plateau
film group there near the Ice Wall.
The uh,
no,
uh,
it was basically that had to keep the
batteries warm by keeping them right
against my skin.
So I keep the batteries right against
my skin and my body weight would keep it
warm.
And the second I wanted to take it out,
I pulled out real quick hit play.
And then it would usually last a minute
or 30 enough to get a little clip or
something like that.
You couldn't just let it run,
but then it would completely freeze.
Even a full battery would be on zero
battery by pretty quickly using solar
panels to charge it.
Yeah.
So one crazy cool thing about Antarctica
and that time of year is it's 24 hours
a day light.
And so the sun never sets.
So even when I'm on my tent
in the middle of the night,
I'm asking your plugs to kind
of pretend like it's nighttime,
but 24 hours a day light.
So solar panels,
I'm keeping everything charged.
Camera's phone,
batteries,
all that.
And Are you traveling
with or are you using gps?
Yeah,
so I had some way points.
The GPS waypoints that kind of
led my path to the South Pole,
et cetera.
But most actually using a compass.
So I look at my gps maybe once
every week or something like that.
Just cause the bearing,
the juice factor,
it's actually just easier because,
so I basically had like a harness on
front of me that would have my gps or my
compass kind of off my chest more or
less because some of the clips we saw the
sun's out.
But actually more than half of
the time the clouds would come in.
So it'd be just complete
and utter whiteout.
I couldn't even see one
step in front of me.
And so I'd actually have to
just stare down at my compass,
keep it on this bearing.
And so imagine you can't see anything,
can't see one step in front of you.
I'm pulling it,
you know,
300 pound sled,
1213 hours per day,
not listening to anything really complete
dead silence and just staring at this
compass bearing all day long.
So
going crazy at all.
I mean,
the mental side of it was by far the
most interesting side of it for me.
Um,
you know,
have a lifelong endurance athlete,
but really kind of an exploration into
the mind is what it was for me and why I
was curious about it.
So spending all this time in silence.
I've done,
are you familiar with,
uh,
a vipassana meditation,
these tips?
So I've done a couple of these 10 days
silent meditation retreats before this,
which is 10 days,
no reading,
no writing,
no eye contact,
um,
kind of dove into that piece of it.
But 54 days alone in Antarctica
and complete silence was,
was next level of that for sure.
Damn.
Dude,
that is so fucking
impressive.
I
can't believe that you did that.
Now when you're looking down and it's
an utter whiteout and you're looking at
your compass and you're
dragging this shit behind you,
like,
are you doing anything in your mind?
Are you like singing songs?
Are you,
what are you doing?
Um,
there's a couple of different things,
but really what ended up happening is I
started to be able to trigger these flow
states.
So,
you know,
as a lifelong professional athlete
through different capacities in my life.
You know,
I've tapped into that.
I was a swimmer when I was a little kid,
so swimming laps in a pool.
Sometimes I would like kind of just happen
to this like timeless space where you
know,
maybe 30 minutes would go by and in
two minutes or something like that.
But I never really knew how I got there.
Just so it's sometimes tap into it,
sometimes not,
you know,
the zone flow,
state,
whatever you want to call that.
But in Antarctica I went in with this
sort of a tension about intention of
exploring that space in my mind.
And so as I got more and more into
these wideouts into these compass,
staring at this compass,
staring at this expansive landscape,
I started to find ways to actually
trigger that flow state in my mind.
So it got to the point where I
could for several days at a time,
be in this deep flow state.
So you know,
my day was about 17 hours
every day between getting up,
boiling my water,
getting out of my tent,
and those crazy conditions,
packing my sled,
dragging it for 13 hours,
setting my tent back up and these storms.
But I got into this sort of sequence
of being so present with each step,
each next sequence that it ended up
being in this really timeless spaceless
place in my mind of true high performance
that was almost like the most deepest,
peaceful,
meditative state that
I can possibly imagine.
It was.
It was very profound and beautiful,
uh,
to get there in my mind.
Wow.
Are you boiling this water in your tent?
Like,
yeah,
so my 10,
yeah.
So it kind of a,
a slightly different
white gas fuels stove.
So not the canisters where
you could throw away,
but like gas that you
could refill the stove,
but his stove with fuel.
Um,
basically the way my tent was,
you saw the outer layer of the tent there.
There's actually an inner part that's a
tent so that there's a vestibule where
basically there's snow inside
the doorway but not outside,
outside.
So I would shovel that snow
from inside of the tent,
vestibule into my pot and be
able to melt the water that way.
Um,
and drank about six liters
of water every single day.
Um,
when I was out there.
It's a lot of snow,
a lot of antiques,
a few hours to melt that.
But people don't realize this in order
cause actually the largest desert in the
world.
Um,
so it's actually very dry.
It doesn't snow very often.
But when it does of course never melt.
And the South Pole was at 9,300 feet.
So not only am I in this desert but
I'm at altitude doing this thing.
So
did you train it out to two?
Did use like one of those
tents to sleep in or,
yeah,
so there's this gym that
Mike and I train out of,
it's called evolution,
healthcare and fitness in Portland.
They actually have an altitude room
there so that it's not even a tent,
but they actually have a full,
a full room where you can,
you know,
got rowing machines.
It's got treadmills.
It's got all that
simulated up to about 14.
How big is the room?
It's about 400 square feet.
High ceilings,
big.
I mean it's not like huge big enough.
Yeah,
it's like a proper room.
I've been in some of those tents before
when I was racing triathlon many years
ago,
a lot of people were starting
to sleep in those tents,
but black people have a hard time and
then they get warm and stuff like that and
a lot fighters use them as well.
Um,
but uh,
but yeah,
it was pretty cool to have a
full room that you can actually,
you know,
be in and move in properly,
um,
for,
to stimulate some of the
high intensity stuff.
Yeah.
And so it would take you hours
every day to make your water?
Yeah,
I would say I was boiling
water for about three,
four hours per day.
So about hour or two in the morning,
hour or two in the evening.
Uh,
it takes a lot of energy to boil,
you know,
frozen snow when it's that cold out.
Um,
so you had to care.
I had to carry a lot of fuel.
That was the other really
heavy component in the sled.
Hundreds of hours of fuel.
Yeah.
So I took about,
uh,
17 liters of fuel,
so that's what I have,
six gallons or something like that.
How'd you know that that
was going to be enough?
Uh,
I did some practicing beforehand.
Um,
I,
in 2016 I did another world record project
where I climbed the tallest mountain
on each of the seven continents,
the seven summits as well as
went to the north and South Pole,
but much smaller polar expeditions a week,
uh,
basically across crossing
the last degree of latitude.
And so when those expeditions
off those on Everest,
during that time,
Denali,
etc. All of that in 139 days.
Um,
but I did that and that kind
of helped me get a sense of it.
But honestly it was also best
guess based on talking to people,
different experts in the field,
you know,
diving into that.
But you never know is it going
to be enough or too little?
I'm here on the side of too much.
When,
when you finally got to the end,
how much did you have left?
So my final push,
I actually,
I woke up on the morning of Christmas Eve
24th of December this past year and it
looked,
I was 77 miles from the finish.
And I had been going at that point,
at the beginning of the trip,
I was only going nine,
10 miles per day.
Towards the end,
I started going about 20,
25 miles per day.
So I said,
you know what,
I'm about three days out.
And then I thought to myself,
maybe if I could push really
hard these next two days,
I could do it in two days,
like two 15 plus hour days.
Like really get into it and started
looking at my fuel and food supplies and
like they were pretty low.
I had,
I had enough fuel,
a few,
a few liters of fuel,
but I actually want to had
about a day or two of food,
like real substantial food left.
Um,
and so I woke up and I was like,
all right,
let's go for this.
And in the actually deepest
talk about flow states,
that was the deepest
flow state of my life.
I woke up in one hour and that
day it's Christmas morning.
Now I wake up and I'm just
locked in and I just came.
I didn't tell anyone back home,
didn't tell my wife who was tracking me.
They had this gps tracker
where they could follow me,
but I was just in my mind,
I was like,
you know what,
not not three days,
not two days.
I'm going straight for it.
And so I did a final 32 hour continuous
push on day 54 77 miles straight,
drag of my sled all the way to get to
the finish line in one continuous push.
No music,
no nothing.
Just like in my head in this,
in this crazy flow state of,
I dunno,
high performance.
Um,
and it was,
it was,
it was a crazy final push to get there,
but made it right before
the food and fuel ran out.
Oh my God.
And then there's,
there's no one there of course,
like you crossed the finish side.
You're like,
done this.
No one in the world has ever done this.
Applause.
Nope.
Zero.
And so what do you do
when you get to the end?
You said,
hey,
I'm done.
Come get me.
Yeah.
How long does it take
for them to come get you?
It took me a week to
get out of Antarctica.
Totally.
It took actually me four days to get a,
but there was a crazy
other component to this,
which is no one in the world
had ever done this before.
And like I said,
a few really talented people,
some of the best explorers in
the world had tried recently.
One guy died.
Um,
and it just so happened there's a really
specific season where you can attempt
this.
But another guy was attempting
this at the exact same time as me.
I'm a British,
a British guy who's a
equivalent of a navy seal,
you know,
British special forces.
The living most experienced
guy in Antarctica is actually
pulled 3000 plus miles
and an article now on various expeditions.
And so we got dropped off one mile away
from each other to begin this thing.
And um,
obviously I was the first,
I did win this race head to head and at
the finish line I waited for him for a
few days cause I wanted to congratulate
him cause he did ultimately finish.
But you can only imagine.
I would feel going back to that
first hour where I was like,
it's impossible.
It was also like,
it's impossible and bow the,
by the way,
this navy seal dude who knows
more about Antarctica to me,
he's often going,
I can see him at a distance just
like leaving me in the dust.
Um,
but fortunately after day
six I caught up to him,
you know,
I waved to him and this weird
like passing of the torch moment,
like I was passing him and then I never
saw him again till I finished and I
finished about 70 miles ahead of him,
about two and a half days ahead of them.
That's got to suck for him.
Or I got this mother Fucker,
I brought it home for America,
man,
you know,
appreciate that.
We all,
we all appreciate that,
but still,
that's going suck for him.
Yeah.
So I actually,
even though I finished and the first
thing I could have kind of wanted to do,
I haven't had,
I haven't had a shower.
I haven't,
I actually to save weight so I
could get as much food and fuel.
My sled,
I brought no extra clothes,
no extra pair of underwear,
like literally no extra pair of underwear.
I don't have to paradise.
So where are you shitting out there?
Everyone wants to know this.
Let's just get it on the table.
I let,
thank you for asking.
Um,
I basically,
I described that vestibule situation.
So one side I cook in,
right?
If the wind is calm,
I get out of my tent,
dig a hole and you know,
go shit and a whole basically.
But when it's real windy,
like those storms,
I just watched like you're going
to get frostbite if you try to,
you know,
bend over,
pull your pants down
when it's minus 80 out.
So in the vest if you will,
of my tent,
not the side I'm cooking on,
but the other side where
I'm still inside covered,
I dig a hole in there and
that was my morning routine.
Get up at 6:00 AM,
start boiling my water on one side
of my tent and it's not glamorous.
It's not a pretty thing.
And to make up,
actually to me,
this is very cool but also not glamorous.
Um,
within one degree of
latitude of the south pole.
So the last degree of ladders at 89
degrees to south pole at 90 degrees.
It's basically 69 miles or 60 nautical
miles circumference around the South Pole
and article being as pristine as it is,
they have all these laws about
environmental conservation,
which to me is amazing.
Being someone who just loves and
has a great steward of the land,
they actually say you can't even leave
your human waste in holes here even
though there's nobody out there.
They're like,
we want this to be
completely protected area.
And so yes,
usually my sled was getting lighter
most of the time cause I was eating food
everyday and burning fuel.
But in that last degree of latitude
to the south pole and crossing it,
I was shitting in a bag,
wrapping it up and putting it in my
sled and having to carry it with me.
So um,
yeah.
Wow.
It shows disciplines
should I was something a lot
of people have been like,
hey yeah,
I put it in a bag.
Fuck you crazy asshole.
Who cares if I dig a shit up there.
It was tempting,
but you know,
so I grew up in the gold
out in the outdoors.
It just as leave no
trace principles that I,
you know,
I really love.
And in particularly in article,
one of the things about Antarctica,
it's one of those places where imagine
you've traveled far and wide and your
life and there's some few places,
at least in my mind where you just,
you can't put it into words
until you've stepped off there.
And for me,
this is my second time in an article.
Both times,
you know,
this big cargo ship basically
lands you on the continent.
Then you get an a smaller plane to get
dropped off to where I needed to start on
the edge of the continent.
But both times stepping off the plane,
I'm just shit eating grin ear to ear
on my face because I just am like,
Whoa,
what is this place?
Even the second time seeing it,
I felt that I'd like,
my cheeks were sore
because I was just smiling.
So big of just pristine beauty.
The blank canvas.
The,
I mean,
you look out on the land and you're like,
human footprints haven't
touched 98% of the continents,
something like that.
I mean it's untouched.
And so shitting in a bag,
if I had to do that to do
my part to keep it that way,
uh,
I did you drag?
Uh,
at the end it was about three.
I reuse the bag.
So
one per day for that section
is about hundred 20 miles.
It took me,
I don't know,
a week or so to cover that distance.
So,
um,
yeah,
added,
added weight to my sled rather
than subtracting during.
That was the middle part of the journey
right around the 30th and 40th day.
Now how did you calculate your nutrition?
The nutrition journey was actually
fascinating and to be honest,
in my opinion,
people said,
well,
how come other people die trying?
Or why did other people
not be able to do it?
Because one other guy ran out of food.
And so when I was looking at this journey,
you know,
we,
again,
we were calling it the impossible first.
Like,
how am I going to make
the impossible possible?
And I thought that the nutrition
piece of it was going to be huge.
I actually,
my dad's an organic farmer in Hawaii,
like whole food health and nutrition has
been a big part of my personal journey.
And so I found a company that
was really in it with me.
So this company called standard process,
there are whole food supplement company.
I'm really involved in Chiropractic and
acupuncture and they presented them with
this and I said,
hey,
what do you guys think?
Like is there a way to
like figure this out?
And they're like,
well we have 20 of the top doctors,
nutritionists,
food scientists,
you know,
on our staff and this innovation
center around nutrition,
like come in the lab with us.
And so they'd never done
this with an athlete before,
but they were intrigued.
And so I actually went and
did a year's long worth of,
you know,
a hundred plus blood test,
vo two Max test,
all this fitness testing
all around my physiology.
And they created ultimately a custom
food solution as I a bar form essentially
called the column Bar.
That was all whole food ingredients.
It was no,
you know,
chemical to rivers or anything.
It was,
you know,
coconut oil,
seeds,
nuts,
you know,
all these different pieces
of macronutrients as well
as micronutrient blends
that I needed,
but custom tailored to my physiology.
Um,
and that's what I mean.
That was the bulk of what I ate.
I ate 7,000 calories per day.
I was burning 10,000,
so even at 7,000,
I was losing about a pound of day,
a way of weight almost,
um,
to my body.
So that's why I needed to get bigger.
But these column bars just burned
super efficiently and my body,
like it was just the
perfect blend of everything.
So eating the same thing every single day
for 54 days might have gotten a little
bit boring,
but my body was just,
it was actually pretty dialed in.
Wow.
Now when they did this and they,
they made these custom bars for you,
did they know how,
I mean,
how did you know how many calories
you're going to be burning where you're
pulling this 300 pound sled?
Was it dependent upon the conditions?
Like if the snow was more packed or IC,
it be difficult.
If it was some soft,
right?
100% so I mean we had
to use our best guests,
honestly,
we had to just say,
let you use our best gas.
I had guys had a bunch of
smart people smarter than me.
We're in this room,
all these doctors,
these PhDs around this.
And we had to make some assumptions
and ultimately they were like,
okay,
you're going to burn 10,000 calories.
Let's get you 10,000
calories in these bars.
And we started running the weight
on the sled and we're like,
that'll be a 500 pound sled.
Like we can't carry that.
So it's this equation of like,
can you make this led light enough to
pull if we can get the nutrition right,
how efficiently does
that burn in your body?
How much can your stomach absorb?
You're hungry the whole time.
More or less?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
I was,
I was ready for a big fucking meal.
I got done.
What's the first thing you ate?
Uh,
this,
the first thing I ate when
I got back was a big burger.
But you might call me
lame for saying this,
but I'm just going to say,
cause it's the truth.
What I craved was salad man.
What I craved was just something,
you know what I mean?
I've been eating like
this freeze dried field.
It's like chunk of Colombar,
which got me through,
but it was like something green and alive.
And so I like this big salad
with avocado and sadly,
no,
I had a big burger too.
But then of course I eat,
my stomach has shrunk,
right?
I eat this big meal and I'm like,
oh my stomach of hurts.
But mostly I was like,
I'm back in the real world baby.
So it was like,
it was everything I could get my hands.
I went to a buffet,
it just was like my stomach was hurting,
but I was like,
I'm not going to stop.
And I just started eating like whatever
croissants and bread was all the things.
So,
uh,
imagine your body would like you
probably craving all that life.
Why live things green?
Exactly.
Vegetables and fruit.
It's weird to say,
I mean like I'm from Portland,
Oregon,
you know,
it's pretty green part of the world up
there in the Pacific northwest and not
even just the,
the food component,
an art.
There's nothing alive out there.
There's no animals on the coast.
There are.
But like in the interior
and I see any animals.
I don't see a bird.
I didn't see nothing.
Right.
And so not only have,
I think as humans we're kind
of wired to see things living.
I mean even here in La,
a bit of a concrete jungle,
but like you see trees on this tree,
you see the ocean,
whatever.
That's what a Nazi,
anything alive for 54 days.
It was like,
wow,
I want to like smell trees,
fresh air and the trees.
I want to eat a salad.
I don't know.
Like that's where I'm like my mind got
to is kind of coming back to reality in
that way,
man.
So when they're constructing
these bars for you,
and this is all based on your body
and like what burns well with you,
how do they like in terms
of like how many cat,
what's the best food in terms of weight
versus calories and is there some foods
that are heavier but don't
have as many calories?
Yeah,
so I think I'm going to get the
numbers pretty close to right here,
but I think per hour fat of course
of the macronutrients we got protein,
fat and carbs.
Right?
Right.
Um,
fat is the most calorie dense of the mall.
You have to make sure these
things don't freeze solid.
Right.
So that was one of the,
it was minus 25 and my
sled every single day.
So it had to actually be edible
while frozen essentially.
Cause it'd be too hard to rewarm them.
Cause this was a food I was
eating outside of my sled.
So what actually frozen too frozen too.
But actually where we,
where the work around happened,
where they kind of their mastermind was,
they were like,
you actually need this macro nutrient
plan to be about 40 or 45% fats because I
needed high fat food,
you know,
um,
to stay alive out there.
And so they basically pumped
it full of coconut oil,
which ultimately,
you know,
does it,
you see coconut on the shelf,
it's not a liquid.
It's actually a solid,
but it doesn't freeze like rock solid.
So having that much coconut
oil in it allowed it to,
we actually had to get it shipped down
frozen because if it didn't freeze it
got,
it actually kind of got like flat.
And so they put it in
these freeze dried packs,
shipped it down to Chile,
had to do this whole
customs thing to import it.
It was like a whole,
like crazy logistical mess.
Uh,
but got that done and it actually held
up so that it was enough fat in there
that I could actually bite off
chunks of this rather than,
you know,
there's plenty of stories of guys and
he's cold places breaking teeth on Clif
bars and you know,
things like that.
So,
uh,
the column bars were,
were,
were at good Goodwell frozen.
So it's mostly
like a lot of fats and seeds and
seasoned nuts.
And then the other thing is that they,
like I said,
they're their bread and
butter at this company.
Standard processes,
they're a supplement company,
so,
but it's all whole food derivative.
So organic farm,
basically a vitamins.
And so they actually intermixed like
probiotics and magnesium and like beat
extract and all these sorts of plant
derivatives as well to give me the Fido
nutrients I need.
That's not giving me the calories,
but that's giving me the,
and I stayed healthy the whole
time and I got super worn down.
I got super skinny,
you know,
all that kind of stuff.
But I actually stayed,
you know,
I never got sick,
I still healthy.
That
was my other question.
Like what was the plan if you did
get sick it was just to wait it out
in the tent,
waited out in the tent.
Um,
you know,
there there's,
there is a contact with anything though.
Right.
So I had,
I had a couple of things.
One is I had my gps,
which I was paying a satellite every
10 but I mean is a life form so no,
no,
no.
Yeah,
sorry.
Um,
yeah.
So that part of it,
there's nothing out there.
So basically if you get a bacteria,
you've brought it out there.
So they actually idea was more or less
to get out there healthy rather than you
can stay pretty healthy in
terms of bacteria and stuff.
Of course you can get pretty worn
down and sick and the cold or flu like
symptoms or that something
you had when you land.
Exactly.
Cause there's,
I mean there's nothing
out there and are you,
were you concerned about that?
Because like I would imagine like the
anticipation leading up to it is a little
stressful and sometimes your
immune system can get run down.
Oh a hundred percent.
You know,
of course it,
uh,
it's fun to recount the epic parts
of these journeys are my other,
you know,
world records climbing Everest or this
summit day or this push or whatever.
But anything that's this long duration,
this was 54 days.
The world record,
I didn't,
2006 was 139 days.
Like the boring answer is like,
how did you do it?
It's like,
well,
like I washed my hands really code when
I went to the airport and I didn't eat
this like food off the street and I,
you know,
staying healthy,
you can't get that right.
You know,
it doesn't matter.
imagine you were on the flight headed
out there and some dude next to sneezing.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Mother,
fuck.
There was a couple of times,
uh,
when I raised triathlon many years ago,
I think I raised in something
like 25 countries over the world,
different places and there are
three or four times I can remember,
like I remember one time
I flew to the Philippines.
It's a place called Subic Bay
gearing up for this big race.
And sure enough,
the night before the race,
just like diarrhea,
like crazy puke in my brains out.
So I,
I jumped into,
I jump into the swim swim in the ocean,
you know,
it's a milestone and feeling like shit.
And I'm like,
Oh,
I'm going to try through
all the Philippines.
Like I got to do this race,
you know.
Sure enough on the bike.
I get on my bike and my bike,
the bike course run right next to
my hotel and I just had no power.
And I was like,
Yup,
I'm turning off in the Filipino guys.
Like,
no,
you're going the wrong way.
The chorus.
And I was like,
Nope,
I'm going to my hotel room
to shit some more basically.
So yeah,
one,
one bad burrito,
one bad.
This can ruin,
you know,
any athletic performance.
I mean,
sorry Rhea,
while you're pulling a 375
pounds sled in it and article.
Oh my God.
Was that a pretty well,
but that is not a pretty bad place with
the one pair of underwear that it gets
even more.
Oh so get,
stay unhealthy was,
was super key to all of this.
But you know,
all things considered I me and my
body of course got banged up some.
But like I came out,
you know,
relatively healthy and I think the
food nutrition was a key part of that.
Oh,
it has to be what?
It sounds like you really did it wisely.
Like you,
I mean that's so cool that you had that
company behind you that organize the
preparation.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Good Lord Man.
Now we trying to put fat on
before you left as well as muscle.
Yeah.
So with Mike,
you know,
the goal was to put,
I put about 10 to 15 pounds of muscle on
and then another five pounds of fat on
top of that.
Just knowing that I've got
total was 20 pounds total.
But you know,
between fat and the last,
the last few weeks I was,
you know,
basically I'd be lifted.
I know I've gotten strong and all this,
didn't want to wear myself out too much,
you know,
stressing my muscles because I
was about to go undergo this.
And it was where I was just
putting calories and inside,
you know,
eat dinner and then Jen
and my wife would be like,
what are you going to edit out?
And a like,
should I be sitting there
to eat and like a pine of,
you know,
coconut bliss,
ice cream,
whatever it was,
you know,
putting calories into just to put some
fat on there cause I just burned off meet
immediately.
I mean it was gone.
So yeah.
So you must have been shredded
by the time it was over.
Yeah,
I uh,
I was pretty,
that there was actually out of,
I'll pull it up,
but there's a photo of my Instagram
that's kind of shows a little bit of the
before and the after body shot,
but I,
uh,
yeah,
I was,
I was very lean,
but it was honestly,
it was also scary.
Like in the end I think
I held up pretty well.
But you're out there by yourself,
you've got no context.
And so I started looking down at my
legs halfway through this journey.
Uh,
yeah.
There I am.
So before and after that
much of a difference.
Yeah,
it's a little,
the light's not great.
You definitely look a lot more lean.
More,
I wouldn't even say a lot more lean.
Yeah.
So it's about 20 pounds different.
But my mind's playing tricks
on me more than anything.
I looked down at my waist about
halfway through and I was like,
Holy Shit.
Like I'm falling apart here.
And I actually started getting in my own
head about am I losing too much weight?
Am I not?
But when I,
when I actually weighed myself afterwards,
like 20 pounds,
like we thought it could have
been as much as 40 pounds.
So you know,
only losing 20 pounds.
All things considered like,
yeah,
like you said,
I don't look that other than that
really cool beard that I grew up.
Um,
so you were ready to get going?
Yeah,
I mean we,
we have planned for that.
We have planned for that.
And like I said,
I started out,
I started out about one 65 I put myself
up to one 85 to leave and I finished at
one 65 so actually finished way
more near my sort of natural,
fairly lean weight for my height.
Perfect plan.
But there's,
there's plenty of things to be wrong,
but kind of planned out
for things going wrong.
Yeah,
I mean I'm,
I'm probably like this,
this was in one one way as a solo effort.
I mean I was out there by
myself walking across this,
but this was a massive team
effort from these guys.
Get behind me,
all these doctors,
you know,
all the different people
I have supporting me,
my,
you know,
my wife and then what she does
with all of the media and the,
our nonprofit and it was the Benny things.
A lot of pieces go into
making this thing happen.
So it was a team effort for sure.
Big Time.
That is so amazing.
Now at the end you get there,
you're done.
But there's no one there.
So what do you do?
You make a phone call?
Yeah,
I'm done.
Come get me.
They know where you are
because they're tracking you,
right?
Yeah.
So what was kind of crazy
was that crazy last push,
right?
It's this 32 hour nonstop push,
uh,
till the end.
And so what happened is it's
Christmas Day when I start this push.
And so my whole family,
uh,
I'm actually,
I have five older sisters,
big family,
you know,
I'm the,
I'm the baby of the bunch and they're
all together and Hood River Oregon at my
sister's house and they're thinking cool.
Colin's like getting close
to end of his project.
We'll track him and everyday they track
me on my gps at ping the satellites
every 10 minutes.
So people,
all my Instagram followers,
anyone could actually follow
the progress in real time.
And they were used to seeing me stop
at about 1212 hours into the day.
So 12 hours into the day
happens and they're like,
okay,
maybe he's going another hour,
13 hours,
14 hours,
15 hours.
They're like,
what's going on?
16 hours.
My whole family is not normally together,
but they're all together
cause it's Christmas Day.
Finally,
18 hours into this push.
I finally stop and pet up away point
because what happened was I ran out of
water even though I said I'm not stopping.
I was like,
I only had three liters
of water after 18 hours,
I need more water so I at least have
to put my tent up to boil water inside.
So what I do,
it's now midnight.
I started at 6:00 AM it's now midnight up.
We going to 18 hours.
A midnight in Antarctica is a,
with the times when I was staying
on was 7:00 PM on the west coast.
So it's Christmas dinner.
I finally call and it's my mom,
my sister,
my wife,
like everyone's on the phone,
they're like,
oh my God,
you did 47 miles today.
That's your best buy,
like 15 miles.
Incredible.
And I was like,
no,
I'm not stopping.
I'm actually just boiling water for an
hour to continue back out for another
like 14 hours to finish this thing.
And they're like,
what?
The weather must be really good.
Wow,
you're feeling so good.
And I was like,
I was like,
actually it's a the worst weather of the
entire trip because this massive ground
blizzard blue,
like,
like our 16 of this push.
It was nice just this ground blizzard,
which is,
it's not actually snowing,
but it feels like it's knowing cause
it's so windy that the snow was blowing
around everywhere.
But I was locked in such a deep flow
state in my mind that even setting my tent
up in this crazy storm,
even getting inside 18 hour push,
I was just like,
Nope,
I've got this.
And it felt like for me,
when I reflect on that moment,
um,
Jenna even says this,
you know,
she talked to me every night and
there there's clips of me crying.
There's clips of me having doubts,
you know,
there was ups and downs
to this whole thing.
She was like,
you sounded the most lucid I've ever
heard you and she's watching me high
performing or things.
She was like,
you were locked in.
And so instead of her going like,
maybe you should sleep
and like get some rest.
She was like,
I trust you.
Like,
I believe you,
like go for it.
She could just hear it in my voice.
Um,
and it was a crazy thing and I it for me,
you know,
I'm 33 years old now and it really felt
like a culmination of my entire life and
a lot of ways like from the swim
practices as a little kid too,
you know,
I got burned in this crazy fire that I
overcame and talking about that if you
want,
I,
you know,
race,
triathlon,
professional,
we all have these moments
with the meditation practice,
the,
the family,
the support,
like suck.
All of these things were stacking on
each other to kind of lead to this final
culminating moment.
And I had to pull on lessons from each
phase of my life to be that locked in.
But I found myself just,
you know,
kind of in that moment,
in that flow state,
um,
being able to get up out of
that hour 18 and say to them,
actually,
I'm going back out and
this crazy ground blizzard.
I got another 14 hours to
go to finish this thing.
And so that was,
you know,
32 hours and 77 miles later,
the final push to the end.
Now what did you wear in terms of like
a base layer and we was there concern
about you sweating while
you're pulling all that weight,
especially initially
when it was 375 pounds.
Yeah.
So you know,
one of the famous lines that,
you know,
people who have been in the polar
environments will say is if you sweat,
you die.
Um,
and you know,
it's maybe a little bit hyperbole
but it's not far from the truth,
which is you start sweating and
you stopped for even 30 seconds.
You're clothes are literally
freezing to your body.
And so it was this crazy kind of kind
of balance of being able to pull this
sled,
get your heart rate elevated enough to
keep your body warm but not too warm that
you were sweating.
And so any second I would start sweating,
I would strip layers off.
So there was times,
especially when there was no wind,
it's still be ambient
temperature minus 20,
minus 25,
but I would just have like a thin
gore tex jacket on and one base layer.
That's it.
I mean we were in Marino.
Marino actually itches my skin,
although it's really good.
But for me I'm a little
bit allergic to it.
Um,
so I work synthetic fabric,
have a synthetic that completely mimics
Marino in terms of the way when it's
moist,
he still stay warm.
Yeah,
somewhere.
Marina.
I honestly,
Marino is amazing fabric for that reason.
Um,
unfortunately for me,
like I said,
it just irritates my skin.
Oh,
funny that you could suffer close,
go maybe feel that.
Uh,
no,
but uh,
so I used to synthetic but it's crazy.
Are you using like what,
what,
what?
Um,
I was using mountain hardware base layers.
and then actually my outer layer,
so this Norwegian company
called Bergen's of Norway,
they don't sponsor me,
but they actually,
believe it or not,
the Norwegians know a thing or two
about being in the polar environment.
And so they've designed a really good
jacket and pant that sexually really
breathable and really good.
And then I suit sewed a for rough,
uh,
onto the edge.
So a wolf,
a wolf,
uh,
for rough on the outer side of the foot.
I think it's Wolffia
Wolf Wolf for thought.
You were saying Whoa,
whoa.
And I was like,
it sounds like wolf.
You know more about this than me.
I'm not the output of know your audience.
I have nothing.
I have not a big hunter myself.
I've never,
never had done that,
a lot of that.
But uh,
yeah,
that's a wolf.
Well,
they know how to survive in the cold.
Yeah,
exactly.
So the base layer is a synthetic.
What is the material
that it's made out of?
The base layer is,
yeah,
it's a thing.
It's a synthetic.
I'm like a poly,
polypropylene,
something like that.
When it sweats,
it dries quickly.
That's,
But the idea was just to not get it wet,
so basically stripped
down as much as possible.
Um,
but like literally I'd go from that and
then of course I needed to eat and drink
every whatever,
30 minutes or whatever,
actually more like every hour.
So I'd stop.
So I'd stop in the front of my sled.
I had a huge puffy down jacket,
like a massive like Michelin man,
huge Buffy down jacket.
So even if you're stopping for a minute
to drink water before even trying to do
that,
boom,
put the big jacket on because that's
how cold or how cold you can get
immediately from stopping.
I mean,
it's just so much colder
than when pulling the sled.
Your heart rate stays up
and keeps you pretty warm.
Imagining like your,
your hands and your feet to
that would be a real issue,
right?
The small digits.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
frostbites real for sure.
Hands outside of the clubs.
That's why some of this stuff I was doing
in the training of get my hands with a
dexterity,
you know,
you have to tie all these
knots with big gloves,
mittens on.
You can't take your gloves off
for any sizable period of time.
Uh,
if you look back on a lot of my photos,
I've actually got tape on my face
over across my nose and my cheeks.
And that's because I started getting
tiny little bits of frostbite,
uh,
on the bottoms,
my nose and on,
on my cheeks because I'd wear a
full face mask buff everything.
But even,
you know,
tiny little,
one,
you know,
needle prick of wind on
your face throughout the day
and that cold it's going to
turn into a cold injury.
And so I started getting a
few cold injuries on my face.
Nothing,
you know,
too bad you're looking at Greece,
your face up or anything like mostly the,
the tape.
Um,
and then so I had a little bit of like
Vaseline or like chap stick type of stuff
on some of the batteries.
The one thing actually that I
did that I had never done before,
we're actually worked well,
it was a tip that I got,
which was my fingers
started cracking really,
really bad from the cold.
And so they were like really
painful and actually was pouring,
putting super glue into all of those,
basically little micro cuts on my fingers,
which when someone told
me that as a trick,
I was like,
really?
But turns out it's
actually really good trick.
So that's kind of super gluing these
cuts on my fingers back together.
Um,
and that actually worked reasonably well.
All things kids.
I mean,
I was all things considered
is the operative word,
but yeah.
Wow.
So you're wearing the,
what about your eyes?
So I'm wearing,
I'm wearing a goggles.
Um,
but you know,
funny enough,
you know,
I had a couple of,
uh,
you know,
fancier,
nicer ski goggles with me.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
there's the tape on my face right there.
Um,
but,
uh,
but yeah,
it's like,
that's actually just
like the normal KT tape,
like a physio tape that you'd
see like athletes wearing.
And I just had it in my repair kit.
It wasn't meant for this purpose,
but I was like,
what do I have that I could put on my
face to block it a little bit better?
Um,
but I had those goggles
on some of the time,
but actually the goggle that I wore the
most was one that you would might use
for motocross.
Um,
cause it has like a plastic
face mask over the front of it.
Um,
cause the wind,
when it was blowing,
it would just kind of blow around.
So sometimes I had this
flea stripped over my face,
but it blow too much.
Um,
and so I had this more plastic face masks,
gas,
so that,
that's the,
that's when you can see lookout frozen.
It's frozen.
It is on the inside.
Oh my God,
man.
There.
And then like this
neoprene mask underneath.
So I had like double facemask double tape,
like anything to just,
you know,
keep me,
keep me more suspected that it
was so high above sea level there.
Yeah.
So you've got whatever it is,
9,000,
300 feet at the South Pole.
So it's basically just
like elevated ground,
but it seems flat.
Right.
But yeah,
I started at sea level.
So you've got,
I'm not only add,
like I'm actually going uphill
all the way to the south coast.
So the first 40 sub days I pulled
that sled up hill completely.
So it was,
I don't think freaks me out.
Yeah.
Like when you were freaking out an hour
in and you hadn't even actually land
yet.
Yeah.
What does,
what thoughts were
going through your head?
Were you thinking,
man,
I need to get someone
to fucking rescue me.
I mean,
it definitely,
you know,
that those moments of doubt,
oh,
this is on Everest.
This is,
we get to this.
Um,
the,
uh,
you know,
what was going through my head was,
was these moments of doubt for sure.
Um,
but one of the things for me,
you know,
to be honest with these
projects that I've created,
I love,
I love pushing my own limits.
I love finding the edges
of my own potential,
all that kind of stuff.
But I also now really enjoy building
these projects that I can share with other
people.
I do this,
I just nonprofit work where there's,
you know,
30,000 school kids tuning into this
project and using this as curriculum in
their classrooms to learn
about climate change,
to learn about whether
atmospheric pressure.
That's a really cool projects like that.
And then just sharing it
with the world at large,
people going like,
this is impossible.
I mean,
how many guys do you know?
That was like one day I'm
going to do this cool thing,
but they like never do it right.
And so actually going after
that and sharing it away,
it's like you might not want
to walk across Antarctica,
but like you probably have some hope or
some dream or some goal that you want to
accomplish in your life.
Like fucking go and do it.
Like get through it.
And so for me,
doing this,
it's funny,
I've,
I've started to think of myself less as
an athlete and actually more of as an
artist and my canvas really
is just endurance sports.
But creating these art projects in the
world that I can create and share with
people through storytelling
to hopefully inspire them.
Do it.
So what was I thinking
in that first hour was,
you know,
I don't,
I don't want my art project
to blow up right in my face,
but more so there was,
this was bigger than myself.
And that's really what
kept me going forward.
Just like I can't let these kids in these
public school classrooms think that I
could after the first hour,
like at these other people that are
their driving inspiration from this,
hopefully like I want to do
this for this larger purpose.
And honestly,
that's,
that's what really kept me going forward
through the really hard times was that,
that,
that connection to a larger purpose of
what I want to put out in the world and
that ripple effect of positivity.
That's awesome.
And then of course you have a
giant team that prepared and,
Oh yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's a lot,
lot goes into it.
So get getting to that,
getting to that starting
line and having that doubt.
But I think,
I mean,
on one level it's also,
it's a human element.
It's,
it'd be easy for me to come
in here and tell the story.
Like,
you know what Joe,
like I'm the biggest bad ass in the world.
No one's walked across
Antarctica and like I did it.
Even though these people
died trying whatever.
Like those are the facts of the situation.
But like the truth is,
man,
like I'm human.
Like I have the wave of human emotions.
I've figured out how to tap into my
mind in a way to do these things.
But like I still experience fear.
I steer x feeling experienced doubt.
I still experienced the ups and downs,
but I have a way of actually being able
to repo purpose or refocus that energy
into positive,
forward momentum.
I think that's what the differences,
but I believe all of us,
all of us humans have
the capacity to do this.
Like you're looking at me,
I'm like a pretty like regular,
like size of the regular looking guy.
Um,
but I think,
you know,
the muscle between my years is
what separates a difference.
And they allowed me to do
this more than anything.
You don't seem to have the darkness that
I usually see and people that do things
like this.
Do you know what I'm saying?
There's a bunch of people that have done
some fucked up things and they all have
some weird darkness.
Yeah.
You know,
I hear what you're saying.
I think for me there's a lot of the
strength comes from a dark moment in my
life.
Um,
you know,
right after college,
uh,
I was traveling around the world at,
you know,
I had no money as a kid growing up,
we're working class background,
painted houses every summer,
but always dreamed of traveling the world.
So I was like,
one day I'm going to travel the world.
So I finished college buddies of mine
are getting like real jobs and whatever
Wall Street and things like that.
And I was like,
you know what?
I saved up $10,000 over
the past six years.
I'm going to take a surfboard and a
backpack and like go see the world with my
life savings.
And so I went and do that.
I'm 21 years old,
you know,
go to Fiji.
I served through Australia,
hitchhike through New Zealand.
I ended up in Thailand
and Europe at a time.
Yeah,
yeah,
of course.
Um,
and you,
so you're familiar with how much fire
and fire dancing and various crazy to
Boucher's things that happen over there.
So I'm on a beach in rural Thailand
and I decided to jump this flaming jump
rope.
Um,
and unfortunately it goes
terribly wrong for me.
The rope wrapped around my legs and
ignites my entire bio body on fire to my
neck.
Um,
and you know,
in an instant my life changed.
You know,
fortunately for me the water's edge,
the ocean was 10 steps away,
so kind of instinct takes over
and I dive into the ocean,
which extinguish the flames.
My Body's on fire to my neck,
but not before about 25%
of my body is severely,
severely burned.
So my clothes were on fire.
Um,
but mostly we got severely burned,
was my legs and feet.
And so I'm in a place,
I want a beach.
There's,
there's no hospital in this.
Since I'm on an island.
There was no hospital.
Instead of an ambulance ride,
I'm on the back of a moped,
driving down a dirt path.
You know,
I'm,
I'm in a one room nursing station,
literally like the size of the room.
We're sitting in there like
this is our sort of hospital,
it's like one bed and I'm just completely
devastated and sort of that they put
me under eight surgeries over the
next week in the middle of nowhere,
rural Thailand surgeries
in a tiny little shack.
And the,
basically there's a cat running around
my bed every time I come out of there,
you know,
quote unquote Icu,
there's a cat running around
my bed and across my chest.
And the doctors are
literally saying to me,
you know,
in the,
in the broken,
you know,
English is,
they're saying,
hey,
you'll probably never walk again.
Normally.
Like you're probably never
gonna walk again normally.
Um,
yeah,
there,
there's a photo of that.
I think if you click over on,
on that to the second one,
it actually shows,
um,
you know,
there,
there's,
what the legs.
Um,
so,
you know,
I was,
and that's,
that,
that photo there with those legs.
That's actually eight weeks
after I was burned so that,
believe it or not,
that's like the,
it starting to look a little bit better.
Um,
all things considered there.
So as you can probably imagine,
I mean,
just the darkest time in my life,
I've been,
you know,
an APP,
I swam through college.
I know I thought of myself as a physically
active person and here I am like
doctor saying,
Hey,
you know,
22 year old kid,
like you'll never walk again normally.
Um,
and to me that they're
the hero in this story,
which is maybe why you don't see the
darkness in my eyes and it's more of the
light.
But you know,
my mother is really the,
the heroine of this tale,
which is she,
she arrived to my bedside around day five,
you know,
flies all the way over to Thailand,
finds me.
Um,
are you,
are you a parent?
I don't know.
Do you have kids?
Yeah,
I don't have kids yet,
but I can only imagine as a parent what
it's like to walk into a hospital room
and see your kid halfway around
the world and this state,
nothing you can do.
And she admits now that she
was crying in the hallways,
you know,
pleading with the doctors for good news,
like he's going to be all right,
right.
He's going to walk,
she's crying every time she
walked into my hospital room,
she walked in with a smile on her face
and it's just air of positivity of being
like,
okay,
call like is bad.
Like what do you want to
do when you get Outta here?
Like let's set a goal.
Like let's get Outta here
and do something positive.
And I'm like,
mom,
you are you crazy.
Like the doctors say,
I'm never gonna walk again
normally like my life is,
I know it,
it's over,
you know this and this
really dark place in my mind.
But she just kept at me day
after day with this positivity,
this,
that.
And I finally was like close my
eyes and I just pictured like,
what am I going to be?
And I close my eyes and I
had this visualization and
myself crossing a triathlon
finish line,
which is not something
I'd ever done before.
I had swam in college but never
biked to run competitively.
Nothing.
But I was like,
you know what,
the able bodied me sometime in the future
is going to be not only walking again
but doing a triathlon race.
And so I said it to her,
I said,
my goal is to race a triathlon one day.
And instead of her
looking at me going like,
well,
I said,
set a goal,
but maybe something more realistic but
it doesn't require you to be running.
Um,
she was like,
great,
let's learn about it.
Pulls out her computer and just literally
starts reading me like triathlon races
are this,
they're this far there.
This distances.
Like I didn't know,
I knew nothing about the sport other
than just like popped into my mind.
It's something I thought
I maybe wanted to do.
Um,
and so that's what I focused on.
I literally have this photo
of me with the Thai doctor.
I'm,
you know,
my legs are bandage to my waist and the
Thai doctors like looking at me crazy,
but I'm lifting these like 10
pound barbells in my head going,
I'm training for a triathlon.
Now.
That guy's like,
you're in Thailand in a
hospital and I'm telling you,
you're never going to
walk a good normally.
Um,
and so,
you know,
flash forward,
two or three months,
I finally get released from this Thai
hospital folks there for three months.
Yeah.
And when I got released,
I still hadn't walked,
you know,
I mean,
I'm in a wheelchair.
Um,
I got carried on and off
the flight back to Portland,
Oregon land back home and uh,
you know,
still still bandaged up.
And my mom,
you know,
says me,
I wake up the first morning
back in my parents' house,
my mother's kitchen,
the house I grew up in,
and she looks at me and she goes,
all right,
Colin.
Now I know you've got
this big triathlon goal,
but today your goal is to
take your very first step.
And so she actually grabs a chair from
our kitchen table and place it one step
in front of my wheelchair and she says,
today you need to somehow figure out
how to get out of that wheelchair,
take one step and step into
the chair in front of you.
And I'm looking at it like,
I don't know if this is possible,
but three hours later,
four hours later,
I'm still staring at this chair and I
finally work up the courage and strength
to get out of this wheelchair,
take the one step and get into
that chair in front of me.
And is the problem that
because of the burnt skin,
it's not flexible,
you can move it and bend it.
Now that's a good question.
So basically what happened with the burn
is it burned me so deep that two things
happen.
One is there was ligament damage,
so ligament damage to my
ankles and knee joints.
And then the way that this,
the heat,
the scarring in the skin is healing
essentially over these mobile joints.
They don't think I'm going
to regain full flexibility,
um,
at full range of motion
essentially in my leg.
So they're not saying
you'll never walk as,
and you won't be able to stand up at all.
Although that was like extremely painful,
but they just didn't think it'd be imagine
walking around without being able to
bend your knees or your ankles
with like full mobility.
So it just was like,
you're not going to be able
to have that back basically.
So sure enough,
I take that first step,
get in that chair the next day.
My mom doesn't take it easy on me.
She just moved chair five
steps away the next day,
10 steps to let you know every day.
A few more steps of,
and not to go on and on,
but basically 18 months after,
you know,
getting released from that hospital,
I find myself in Chicago.
I finally took a job in finance,
just trying to get out
of my parent's basement,
like get on with my life at 23 years old.
Like,
yeah,
I gotta get like a real job.
Get Out of my parent's basement,
you know,
move to Chicago,
take a job in finance and uh,
try to get my shit together basically.
And I honored that course that,
you know what,
I'm going to sign up for
the Chicago triathlon.
I live here now.
Join a local gym.
Knew nothing about the sport still.
I'm like asking random guys at the gym
like anybody here race a triathlon?
Like I'm going to spin class.
Like how do you,
like how do you like take your
shoes off and like run afterwards?
How do you,
like how does it even work?
Like ask these questions and sure enough
through that process I like train at
this gym,
sign up for the Chicago triathlon,
ended up racing the race,
cross the finish line.
And to my complete and utter surprise,
I didn't just finish the race,
but I actually won the
entire Chicago triathlon,
PT,
4,000 other people coming first place.
So first,
whenever.
Wow.
And what kind of training did you
do to prepare yourself for that?
I mean,
like I said,
I,
you know,
I had been a collegiate swimmer,
so I was a division one swimmer.
I swam at Yale University.
Uh,
but then,
you know,
the biking and running
was completely new to me.
Show you how to do it or did you
just start running and biking?
Yeah,
I literally walked into
the spin class I guess,
but not like a,
like a didn't actually ride a bike.
So I went to the spin class and like
start like met a guy and he was like,
Oh,
I've done one triathlon before.
And he was like,
I can hear you.
So he took me out on a couple
of rides with his buddies.
I had this like steel frame bike.
I didn't know all of these,
like carbon wheels and aero helmet,
you know,
all these fancy like
triathlon type of things.
Like didn't know much about it.
And literally for a summer,
just kind of like asked
people some questions.
This.
And what's funny about triathlon,
I don't know how familiar
you are with this sport,
but um,
in a,
in a race like the Chicago triathlon,
there's,
you know,
for more than 4,000 participants.
And so unlike a marathon where
everyone just starts at the same time,
you actually have to start in waves like
a hundred people every five minutes.
And I was the 39th wave of 53 and so
I dive into Lake Michigan and there's
people that already started like two hours
before me and there's people starting
two hours after me.
And so when I finished the race,
you know I swim,
I bike,
I run,
it was Olympic distance
triathlon so it was a mile swim,
25 miles pike,
6.2 mile run.
I crossed the finish line.
I don't still know I won the race
because like people started before me,
people started after me and they
take the cumulative time at the end.
And so I like my grandma's there
cause she lived in Chicago,
like gives me a big hug.
Like I'm so proud of you.
You were able to walk again and
here you are finishing triathlon,
let's go get lunch.
And so I grabbed my wetsuit and my bike
and my grandma and I sit down to have
lunch and as we're
walking back to the car,
she's like,
do you want to see like what
place you came in your age group?
And I was like,
sure.
Like that would be cool.
Like let's go see how I did.
And we won.
Drove her to like the scores table.
And the guy's like,
I'm like,
Oh,
you know,
I'm trying to figure out a
place or what's your name?
I was like,
Oh,
I'm calling a,
they're like,
we've been calling your name
over the for last 20 minutes.
I'm like,
oh,
why did I like do something wrong?
And they're like,
you won,
like,
like my age group.
And they're like,
no,
you won like the whole race.
It was just this surreal,
surreal moment.
Uh,
if I live,
I mean,
it was,
it was wild,
but it,
um,
you know,
for me in that moment what I thought back,
I was like,
it was cool to pat myself on the back.
Like,
Holy Shit.
Like I just did this crazy thing,
but it was more so going back to your
initial question about the darkness versus
the light,
at least in my journey was I was like,
wow,
like this is a sliding doors moment.
Like what had happened had my mom not,
you know,
come in with this air of positivity and
forced me to set this tangible goal.
Like I'm certain my life would
be nowhere where it was today,
but then it's not,
I wasn't like,
Oh wow,
I'm some superhuman freak
that can do these things.
I was like,
wow,
humans,
all of us,
we all have these reservoirs of untapped
potential inside of us and can achieve
extraordinary things when
we set our minds to it.
And so what it did for me,
it's just sparked this curiosity like,
well,
what else can I do if I set my mind to it?
So sure enough,
it was a Sunday when I
raised a Chicago triathlon,
coincidentally,
um,
met who became a huge mentor and
influenced my life that afternoon.
Um,
a guy named Brian Gelber who ended up
being my first sponsor and he said to me,
you won the Chicago triathlon today.
Do you think you should maybe
do something about that?
And I was like,
yeah,
but I've got a job and
I don't have any money.
Like I would need a sponsor.
He's like,
he's like,
I'll be your first sponsor if it's
something you want to take seriously.
And so literally that was on a Sunday.
Monday morning,
I walk in and quit my job immediately.
At two weeks later,
I'm living in Australia,
trading triathlon fulltime and ended up
racing triathlon professionally for the
USA national team,
you know,
all over the world for the next six years.
So it was this crazy moment.
What happened ultimately with the
injuries that you sustained from the fire?
You know,
all things sincere.
That was,
so that was January 14th,
2008,
so to just over 11 years ago now.
Um,
and I,
uh,
you know,
I ultimately have been pretty all right.
I mean I've got some scars but it's pretty
faint and was able to gain back most
of the full flexibility in my legs.
If you look at my left foot is
where the worst worst burns.
But where the rope really just like sat
on my foot for a long time must have um,
that's still pretty
thick with scar tissue.
Um,
you know,
when I'm in the mountains,
when I'm in places,
you know,
like climbing Mount Everest,
like I did like pulling across Antarctica,
all the things I have to be really aware
cause my skin regulates heat not in the
best way he and cold,
it's still just like,
you know,
not like normal scans.
The scar tissue,
the scar tissue just is,
it's just carries the heat a little
bit different for some reason I guess.
I don't know exactly why not as
porous because it's exactly in the,
I'm actually in the early
days for the first five years,
I don't get this so often anymore,
but in the first literally
five years of this,
if I bumped my legs until
like a table or someone just,
you know,
bumped a chair and immediately
know nothing like lightly,
I would usually get a little cut there.
So it's just super fragile.
It was almost like,
you know,
glass skin kind of.
Um,
what's the,
with not the same sort of
flexibility that you'd normally have,
but you know,
10,
11 years on now,
I would say it's pretty much 100%.
I mean,
the things I've done with my legs
and body in the last 10 years,
I think proof,
at least that my body is doing all right.
So I feel extremely,
extremely fortunate to over cover it as,
as well as I did.
And you know,
more than anything I,
I attest that too,
of course,
the,
the physical ability for my body
to recover in the way it did.
But I think that,
at least for me,
started with the mine,
started with that
positivity of my mother and,
and the duration of the many different
things I've done done since then.
And you said you sustained ligament
damage to your joints and your knees?
Yeah,
yeah.
So there was basically,
um,
again,
I'm,
I'm not,
uh,
my,
my anatomy,
I have other skills with
my full anatomy is not a,
I'm not a doctor,
let's put it that way.
Um,
but yeah,
basically the ligaments particular
on the backs of my knees,
so I don't know exactly what that
ligament is that goes through,
um,
through there.
But,
um,
that was really jammed up with,
with the scar tissue.
So I wasn't able for a long time to
fully bend my knees and flex them in the
full way.
And the same thing,
uh,
in the ankles,
whatever that ligament is,
that goes sort of basically turn,
not,
not your Achilles,
but the other side of your foot.
Basically.
That part was just so much scar tissue
had formed a way the skin was healing
around that.
And from the damage to the ligament,
it wasn't sort of being
able to fluidly flex,
uh,
in the way that you
normally would see a foot.
So full they imagined point margin might
be on a point your foot basically if
you're,
you know,
putting your leg forward out,
back like kicking like that.
So yeah,
for a long time and it was kind of a,
so it was kind of like dragging
my feet around in that first year.
Um,
and uh,
so did you have to just push through
the scar tissue and break it up?
Yeah,
I mean it was a lot of,
a lot of obviously PT,
a lot of,
uh,
massage.
Um,
I'll,
I'll tell you a funny story.
It's funny,
I haven't thought of this story.
They log type of,
uh,
the,
if ever told this story actually.
But,
so when I got burned,
I've been traveling by myself
in Thailand or around the world,
but I actually met up with my childhood
best friend named David Boyer who
actually,
uh,
re married my sister
and they have two kids.
So my childhood best friend
turned into my brother in law,
which is pretty fun.
But,
uh,
anyways,
um,
he had been,
he had actually been with
me when I got burned.
So those first five days in the
hospital before my mom got there,
he was with me.
Um,
and was,
it was a saint,
you know,
we're both these scared little 22 year
old kids and he's like trying to do his
best to look after me
and he's freaked out.
But when I get back to Portland,
his mother,
who was kind of a second
mother for me growing up,
my name's Kate Boyer.
Um,
she obviously was like,
wow,
this could have been my son.
Just as you said it had been,
you know,
her son,
just kind of felt like protective of me.
So she comes over to my
house one day and she goes,
you know,
I've been doing some
untraditional healing work.
Would you be open to that?
And at this point was like,
I'll take anything.
What do you guys mind?
And she was like,
well,
I've,
I've been working with this,
a pranic healing Shawmut uh,
do you want to want to check that out?
And I literally was like,
I was like saying yes to
everything at this point.
Like I'm looking for any way to recover.
And I was like,
well,
what is it?
And she was like,
well,
we don't even touch you.
It's just light healing.
And so I go to this basement,
uh,
in Portland and I meet this,
this guy,
and he's sitting there with a bucket
of salt in front of him and he starts,
he doesn't touch me at all.
He's just like waving his hands in
front of like my body and my heart.
And then he's like looking
really intensely at my foot
and I sit there for like
an hour.
I never touches me,
nothing.
He's just like looking at me,
waving his hand in this and,
and he's like,
okay,
I'm done now.
And I'm like,
okay,
what did you do?
And he was,
you know,
telling opened up this shocker.
I opened up that I did this,
but what I mostly did was I put this
force field of white light or right foot
and I'm like,
I mean I'm,
I'm pretty,
I've down with some
untraditional traditional stuff,
but I was kind of like [inaudible] cool.
Like thanks,
I appreciate it.
He's doing it.
And I was like,
what's this bucket?
And he was like,
this is the salt bucket that takes the
negative energy away from your foot and
your leg and puts the negative energy in
there as I'm bringing in this light and
says pranic healing.
And he's like,
so you have this light blue forcefield
over your left foot right now,
which was the worst burn part of my body.
I,
he goes,
I would recommend not showering for the
next couple of days as you might wash up
the force field.
So jails.
So I tell this story with the total smile,
a cheeky smile on my face
because that's funny.
I haven't thought of
a story a lot of time,
but I will say that the next day I
walked further than I had the rest of the
time.
So you want to call that placebo,
you want to call it whatever I emotionally
was it fully bought in on the Pranic
healing.
I'll be,
like I said,
I am into very a lot of
alternative modalities.
God,
I wish it was true.
I met a lady at the comedy store once,
told me she does reiki healing.
She like Kinda rubbed her hands
together and waved him in front of me.
I'm like,
what are you doing?
She's like,
do you,
do you feel that?
I'm like,
don't feel shit.
I don't know what you're talking.
Rough.
So that,
that part,
I don't know if it
worked or it didn't work,
but the,
the combination of the
amount of people with,
you know,
in the hospital with
the physical therapist,
with my mother at home,
with Kate boy taking me
to the pranic healing,
a culmination of all of those
things somehow did unlock the,
uh,
the scar tissue and allow me
to make a full recovery or,
I mean it was a lot of hard work for,
you know,
a year plus to get back on my feet.
But I got there.
Well,
I'm sure there's something to be said
for believing or at least having positive
thoughts about your healing and making
sure that you look at it in terms of like
this can be done.
But
yeah,
no,
I mean very skeptical.
The salt man,
like I said that the salt
man take it for what it is.
Like I said,
I'm telling that story not as an
advocate for product Kaylene necessary,
but I will say agreeing
with what you just said,
there is something about that.
There's something about being wrapped
in the positivity that I was with my
mother in that moment of just being like,
Hey,
like let's get through this,
let's figure this out together.
Like let's focus our mind on something.
And a lot of,
you know,
even as I go through Antarctica,
how,
you know,
how did you do that?
Like,
you know,
people ask me this question like,
are you a superhuman?
And I'm like,
yeah,
I'm a superhuman.
And so were you like,
that's how I feel like we all have this
capacity in our minds to unlock all
sorts of things.
I don't care.
I mean,
if you want to paint pictures,
compose music,
start a business,
you know,
sit,
sit in a warehouse,
into a podcast,
whatever it is you want to do,
she can fucking do amazing things like Ed,
you know,
having that belief does,
does add up to that.
I mean that's step one in my opinion,
is visualizing that,
believing it.
On the flip side,
having a negative self worth or a negative
opinion of what you're about to do or
a negative thought about
the future can also manifest all sorts.
Terrible results.
Absolutely.
Gotta think mean.
Placebo effect is a real thing.
We know that,
right?
We know that if you really do believe
that you're going to get better because of
some sugar pill they give you.
There's a tangible result,
100% if you really believe.
Yeah.
So if that salt guy,
if the thing about all
that stupid shit is,
if you believe it,
it actually has an effect.
I mean there's,
there's a lot of healers out there that
at least on paper are totally full of
shit.
But if you believe in these assholes,
yeah,
they can have such difference.
It's very slippery.
The human mind is such a slippery thing.
I mean,
I'll,
I'll go back to my own
experience and again,
uh,
I don't know how a femoral
are out there you want to get,
but I'm out there in
Antarctica 54 days alone.
Like I'm telling you,
I'm doing this for this bigger purpose.
I'm feel like I'm tapped into that.
And like legitimately there were moments,
at least for me,
whether I'm manifesting that in my mind,
whatever you want to call it,
that I am actually feeling energetically
uplifted by the people pushing me on.
Like there were days that were incredibly
hard where I would sit there and I'd
be like,
oh my God,
I don't know if I can do this.
And I'm done.
Like boom.
Like I would get over,
I would hit with this
serve larger purpose,
that's larger outcome.
And again,
like I'm not,
I'm not a super religious person.
I was actually raised on a hippie commune.
Like I come from a pretty
untraditional background,
but like the energetic field,
whatever you want to call that or if
that's just the belief in something,
you know,
the power of that.
Like I felt the strength
from those moments.
There was moments when my body's
switched from kind of being negative.
Oh my God,
another hard day out here.
it's minus 25 to tapping
into those flow states.
So again,
I don't,
I don't have perfect words for that.
Um,
you know,
I'm starting to try to build
my vocabulary around that.
But that energy,
I think it was derived
from what you're saying.
If you start to believe it,
if you can believe like,
hey,
there's a larger purpose in this,
or hey,
this blue force fields and one foot,
there is something that
if you can originate that
positivity in your mind that I
think can give us incredible
amounts of strength,
um,
and then we can tap
into something greater.
Well,
I think there's definitely something to
what you were saying about the untapped
limits of the human
potential and that there's,
most people barely scratched
the surface of that.
And if you really firmly get into that
zone and believe you can do things that
people just,
they really don't have any idea what they
can do if they have to because people
are rarely pushed to their actual limits.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
it's been said many times before I say it,
but at that,
that idea that growth happens
outside the comfort zone.
And one of the things that I've personally
thought about a lot in this space is,
you know,
I got severely burned in this fire.
I didn't,
well,
I chose the jump the rope.
So I was chose to be a knucklehead 22
year old kid on a beach in Thailand.
But like I wasn't like,
God,
I want to get severely burned today.
Like that happened to me.
Right.
Which forced me through this intense,
tragic moment.
But from that,
I was able to learn of this sort of
untapped potential inside of me because of
the outcome,
because of winning this triathlon.
But what I realized is that it's
hard to choose that path often.
It's hard to push yourself
outside of those boundaries,
but things that are,
you know,
quote unquote forced on you.
I mean,
let's look at something that half of
this population essentially does give
birth,
like childbirth,
natural childbirth,
right?
It's been happening since the beginning
of time and that's an incredibly intense
physical manifestation of
the power of the human body.
I mean,
I can't even imagine obviously
what that would look like,
nor will I ever be able
to experience that.
But that's incredibly powerful.
Or times when people,
you know,
are forced to go through a
cancer diagnosis and have
to go through radiation and
chemo and you know,
facing the mortality and
all this sort of stuff,
people get through those.
But oftentimes these tragedies have to
be forced upon us for us to do them.
And so my exploration now with my,
what I,
you know,
creative artwork,
I call it,
with these expeditions,
these world record projects
that push my body and mind,
it's me choosing to
step into those moments.
It's me choosing to put my body in mind
in these intense moments because of a
deep curiosity of like,
what are the limits of human potential?
You know,
what are my limits?
What are our limits collectively and can
my physical expression of this inspire
other people to innovate,
create and do amazing things in the
world and in and other modalities and
canvases?
Well,
that's one of the weird
things about people doing
extraordinary things like what
you did is that you absolutely will give
other people fuel to accomplish things
in their life.
Inspiration is so
critical for human beings.
I mean,
I draw upon it from so many different
sources from David Goggins and a bunch of
my other friends,
my friend Cameron Hanes,
and a lot of other people
that are endurance athletes
and different people that
have been interviewed on this podcast.
But there's something that happens
when you realize that people can do
extraordinary things that makes
you believe in the potential,
not just in that person,
but also in yourself.
Absolutely.
I mean,
you know,
God is a great example of that.
I've never met him,
but I know I've personally
derived inspiration from that guy.
I mean,
he gets out there,
you know,
you can't run a hundred miles.
Like I'll show you like
I run a hundred miles,
you know,
and he's pushing his by two extreme ways.
Or you know,
I love what he says
about the 40% you know,
I think about it a little
bit different in my mind,
but like what are those limits?
I mean,
don't know if it's 40% of people quit.
You know,
people quit that I can't.
Voice comes up and you know,
he's proven it.
So as many other people have actually,
when you say I can actually,
when you don't stop,
you get stronger.
And for me in my own
story and my own journey,
I think that final day that finally
final 32 hour push proves it three days
before that,
you know,
I'm videotaping all this.
I'm trying to capture as much content
to be able to share with people of this
crazy weird place that's
an article by yourself.
And like day 49 day 40 50 like
I'm literally crying into my goal.
Probean like I'm running out of food,
I'm exhausted.
I don't know if I can keep doing this.
I'm just like worked.
Right?
But sure enough,
I don't say I can't,
you know,
it's that for,
it was at 40% was that 50% that's that
moment when I wanted to quit or I should
have quit.
But then the strongest,
most amazing moment of my entire athletic
career that spans decades happens
three days later because I kept pushing.
It's not like I rested for
three days and pulled that off.
Like I never took a rest day in 54 days.
I pulled my sled to 13 hours every
single day and on the last day it was the
strongest as possible.
So I think it proves if
we can push through that,
I can't moment.
No,
it's not going to work.
That you can get there.
And unfortunately,
you know,
we talk about 40% with Goggins.
I actually think a lot of people quit at
1% they're sitting behind their office,
they're like,
you know,
one day I want to travel
overseas or you know,
I hate this job.
You know,
I've got this great business idea,
but I made it.
And they're like,
but I can't,
like I've got no money
to start this business.
I've gotten no this,
like when I first set off my first world
record in 2016 2014 I sat with Jenna in
my house,
one bedroom apartment with
a whiteboard and were like,
I'm gonna see if I can set the world
record for the explorer's Grand Slam.
Something fewer than 50 people in the
world have ever done and I'm going to be
the fastest time ever is coming to not
only climb Kilimanjaro in northwest South
Pole,
back to back.
I hadn't climbed a bunch of mountains.
Be Pretty easy to say I can't.
Oh,
and by the way,
we have no money to do this.
We have no platform.
I have like 200 Instagram followers.
Like,
I mean I have like nothing,
but we just sat there were like no.
Instead of saying I can't,
let's say I can't,
what's the first step to that?
We literally get out our laptops
and I'm like going to like,
we were like,
we want to build this big media campaign
where lots of people follow and get
pressed.
Like we know nothing about.
We have no background this week.
Google.
What's the difference
between marketing and PR?
I mean we are literally asking Google
the most basic of all basic questions.
Oh,
but you know,
we,
we continue to say like,
let's get coffee with our one friend
who knows something about this.
We should probably get a website.
How does one build a website?
And it goes on and on like this.
How long ago did you start this journey?
So that,
that was 24 when we,
2014 when we dreamed that up.
This will,
the world record was to
see if I could years ago.
Yeah.
So just see if I could set the world
record for something called the explorer's
Grand Slam.
So let's come and tallest mountain
on each of the seven continents,
seven summits.
And before that,
had you done anything like that
or did it just been athletics?
So I grew up in Portland,
so I grew up like in the outdoors,
but like I mean to go climb
Everest and Denali sort of thing.
No,
like the short answer is I'm
going to climb a few mountains,
you know,
it's not like I'd never
been in the snow before.
I'd worn crampons ice.
It's like,
and I had zero experience,
but like not even close to the experience
that you would think one would need to
do that.
And to just break world records,
not just be the fastest
person to ever complete it.
You know?
Like I said,
it ended up being 139 days straight
through to climb all those mountains.
Didn't know.
Oh,
I think we had a clip up a second
ago if something on Everest.
But uh,
but yeah,
I mean to do,
to do all of that,
it started from this place of not of,
of a believing I can.
And then,
you know,
it's again,
it's fun to talk about
the epic adventure buddy.
We,
for me,
it's actually fun to talk about what
happened behind the scenes of that because
what actually happened,
like people applaud our success.
Now this is me.
This is you walking across the ladder,
that's you know,
about 300 foot hole,
a crevasse,
uh,
on the other side of it that you have
to go through to on your way up the,
uh,
the Mount Everest climbing route.
And so your crampons or clicking on the,
on the,
and you're hooking them on
the ladder as you walk across.
And if you fall,
you die.
Yes.
Okay.
So watch this again.
This is so awful.
It's so awful.
Look at,
cause
you're,
you're basically just
walking this tight rope on.
Let me hear it.
Listen to that click folks,
I implore you to go to the Instagram
page so you get the full freak out.
They're tied together
to those ladders ties.
Yeah.
Can he as can be it?
The 300 foot cavern over there?
Oh fuck.
All this cheese us.
Oh,
and you're looking down
because you have a Gopro on it.
Oh,
he cut the sound off at the end there,
but I go at the bear and I go because
it's like there was 50 of those letters,
but I was cheering every
fucking time I got cross.
I was like,
yeah,
one more down.
Woo.
Oh,
did that 50 times in the Khumbu actually
go through that section a couple of times.
It's a very dangerous
section of the mountain.
But yeah.
When about 50 of those ladders.
So when you went through Everest,
did you see the bodies?
Um,
so I fortunately didn't
see any bodies up there,
unfortunately,
are unfortunate.
Fortunately.
I mean,
I'm not like trying to see that bias,
you know,
but the are they're more prevalent on
the climbing around on the north side.
The day that I did summit,
um,
three people tied,
uh,
on the day that I summited.
So when I,
yeah,
when I so does set the,
I mean,
talk about Everest,
I mean for me is major setbacks.
It was the eighth of nine
expeditions in this sequence.
So I'd done a hundred days
of other expeditions leading
up to Everest to do this
explorer's grand slam world record.
I'm trying to climb Everest.
I'm exhausted from a hundred days.
I just come from the North
Pole before that Kilimanjaro,
before that,
you know,
Elbert's all these other mountains.
And then I make my summit push on Everest.
I'm not climbing with a guide or anything,
it's just myself and one Sherpa who I
met climbing in Nepal the year previous
when I was training for this.
And so it's just the two of us and we
climb up into camp for so ever says,
you know for camps there's base camp and
then there's camps progressively higher
in the mountains so you can get your
body a climatize and we get up into camp
for,
have you read the book into
thin air by Jon Krakauer?
Anything about it?
Say,
okay,
there's a famous book that's written
about it where 11 people die and right in
this moment it's called the death zone
where you enter above 26,000 feet.
The human body basically
can't survive for long.
Even with supplemental oxygen and this
massive snow storm and wind storm blows
in like kind of out of nowhere and
we're trying to push for the summit.
It takes us two and a half hours just
to set up our tent and get inside.
And we know like it's over.
Like we're not,
we're not going to summit
Everest like in this storm,
there's no way.
So we just survive the night,
wake up the next morning,
still getting pounded by this weather
and actually have to climb back down the
mountain.
So climb back down the mountain all
the way to camp two and they're like,
and they're like,
well that's probably it.
Like you don't usually like spend a night
out in the death zone and like make a
second attempt and you've already
tried all these other mountains.
You're a hundred plus
days in this journey.
And I was like,
man,
I want to see if I can get back up there.
Like,
and this other guy who I met on another
team had some supplemental auctions.
So I had to use some of
my supplement auction.
So my supplies tours
are limited now as well.
And so he,
uh,
he says to me,
Hey,
I'm not going to go up.
I'm sick,
but if you get back up to camp four,
there's a couple bottles of oxygen
that you could use of mine if you,
if you somehow get back up there.
So sure enough,
per sang [inaudible] name of the shirt
palace climbing with amazing climber
himself.
We get back up to camp
four and the death zone.
And uh,
we decided we're going
to go for the summit.
We call back down to base camp.
What's the weather forecast?
And they're like,
well,
it's the exact same
forecast we told you before.
It might hold,
in which case you'll be fine or it might
turn into what you guys just survive.
And if you're not near your tent and
you're up on the summit ridge of Everest,
like it's going to get like pretty bad.
And so we kind of go back and forth.
Should we go for it?
Shouldn't we go for it?
We just decided to go for it.
But this crazy thing happens,
which is you may have read about this
or heard of this if you know much about
ever is,
but basically no one climbed
Everest in 2014 or 15 cars,
a huge avalanche killed 16 shorter's
in 2014 that the mountain was closed in
2015 there was a huge earthquake in
Nepal that shut the climbing season down.
So no one's even climbed
the mountain in two years.
But all of a sudden because
of these weather delays,
I ended up there and there's a hundred
people going for the summit on the exact
same day.
So basically traffic jam on the worst
fucking place to be in a traffic jam
possible.
So put sang Bodie and I,
we go,
okay,
let's figure out how to climb this thing.
And we leave camp.
You know,
there's a photo that I took for leaving
camp and there's all these lights going
up the side of the mountain and it's
because there's one rope that everyone
works to put in.
So everyone's using the same rope and
all of a sudden we're behind a hundred
people.
And if you stand there,
wind chill.
Minus 40 degrees,
like we're going to get frostbite,
like we're going to
not be able to make it.
And so per sang Bodie and
I look at each term ago,
let's unclipped from the rope.
And so we actually decided to,
we actually decided to unclip from the
rope climb up all the way to the balcony
from the,
the south call.
The death zone area was mentioning before,
um,
up to about 28,000 feet on rope because
we actually think it's more dangerous to
climb roped next to all the behind all
the people than it is to risk of fall.
You don't know those people.
They're like,
and people work.
I mean,
you're on Everest at 28,000 feet.
People are walking,
I mean,
one step per minute sometimes.
it's,
it is brutal.
And so,
I mean,
I'm walking maybe two
steps every 30 seconds,
but I'm like you saying
bolt like pasties people.
Yeah.
This is,
this gives an example of like,
so you're it like the world,
the worst place in the world to be,
you know,
it,
uh,
in a traffic jam.
As you can see here for this photo,
I posted,
uh,
that day.
Um,
but anyways,
I get up to this edge and it finally,
it's too steep.
It's too dangerous for us to be
unclipped from the rope any longer.
And we're like,
we're just going to have to
clip in and settle in behind.
You know,
we'd pass like 50 or 60 people,
so we're in much better place than ever.
I still have this one big puffy coat
has actually the same puffy coat.
I use an Antarctica,
the big like Michelin
man coat and I'm like,
we're going to slow down.
I better put this big jacket on.
And so I take my jacket off,
I undo my gloves real quick to put this
big jacket on over me to warm myself up.
And I looked down and
my right hand is black,
like just black is black,
can be.
And I'm like,
Holy Shit.
Like telltale sign of frostbite,
like,
oh my God,
like it's same thing.
We've got school kids bowling alone,
got family fund the whole thing.
And I'm like,
oh my God,
like I'm gonna route lose my right
hand is Jenice still gonna love me.
You know,
what's my family going to think?
And then I don't say
anything to put Sang Bodie.
I jammed my hand back in
this big gloves and I go,
okay.
And I don't,
I don't recommend this thought process,
but I go,
well if I'm going to lose my hand anyways,
wouldn't it be cooler to lose my hand?
But also have summited Everest.
So how black was it?
I mean it was a lack like black,
black,
like black.
He was black.
Did you take a picture of it?
So,
so the sun had was just still,
the sun was just below the horizon.
So it was like dusk.
And I look down at this point
and on the sun comes up.
So I jammed my hand back in this club
and I don't say anything to per sang
bought him,
like let's keep pushing for the summit.
So we go for the next three hours
and the whole time I'm on I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm such an idiot.
Like I'm going to lose my hand,
my hand's prospect and this and that.
And so we'd get up and we're about 30
minutes blow Mount Everest summit and
should be a beautiful moment for me.
Like since a little kid I dream like
summiting Everest would be like the
greatest accomplishment
of my life on my God.
And I'm thinking like
just in this dark place,
but also haven't taken a
single photo basically.
And I'm like,
why?
Got To get like a photo or a video of,
you know,
the famous Mount Everest summit.
So I pull up my GoPro to shoot a video.
I shoot this short little video,
which kind of shows this crazy
exposure that I'm on one side,
5,000 feet down into China on one side,
5,000 feet in Nepal and this
tiny little knife edge ridge.
And of course I have to
adjust my gloves again.
This is from the summit and I pull my,
I pull my GoPro out,
have to mess with my gloves,
put it back in,
and I look at my hand,
I start going away from
my arms in the air,
go per se,
Bodie,
my hands back.
And he's like,
what are you doing?
It just so happened that the,
the glove warmers in my of clubs,
the chemical hand warmers had broken
open and the charcoal and the copper
filings of the chemical hand
warmers had tied my hand flack.
Oh Geez.
Aunt was completely fine.
Oh God.
So yeah,
this clip here,
if you play it from the top is me reaching
the summit that's per sag Bodie right
there.
But,
uh,
I'm on the summit of Mount Everest.
No words can describe.
Wow.
So what did you experience any
discomfort in your hands before?
So you're,
again,
we're talking about a lot of this,
this podcast bit about mindset,
which is one of my favorite topics.
And like,
just like we said,
you could convince yourself that
the salt man is fixing your foot.
Yeah.
Like,
I'm on Everest,
I'm at 28,000 feet.
My brain's not working very well.
I know that the weather's coming in bad,
that people are going to get maybe
frostbite based on the forecast.
And I looked down and
I see my hands black.
Where does my mind go?
It's like,
it's not like,
Oh let me think about this.
My hand warmer must've broken open and
this I'm like my hand and now it was
weird cause I was like,
I didn't feel my hand getting cold.
My hand like it was fine,
but I'm on Everest in my hands.
Black.
That means,
you know,
in my brain I'm like,
I have frostbite.
So it's just like,
it's a weird thing where
you can take your mind.
Like a lot of this stuff,
the positivity of this.
My mom went to the negative immediately.
Like your hand's gone.
It's frozen off like the end.
Um,
so what happened to the people that died?
Were they on the rope?
Yeah,
so unfortunately that day the weather
actually did get pretty bad in the day.
So fortunate I was able to get down
before the weather got too bad.
Um,
but,
uh,
the people that died that day,
one slipped and fell down
these ropes over on Lhotse,
which is the adjacent mountain,
but sharing some of the same
ropes on the same route.
Um,
and then two people died
from altitude sickness.
So basically either running out of oxygen
up there and not be able to get back
down to their tent.
I think those people actually did get
carried back down to their tents that
night and then died in
the tents that night.
Some it's called cerebral edema,
um,
which is basically your brain fills with
fluid from being at the high altitude
and not getting enough oxygen.
And it's a,
it's a killer up there.
And you know,
one of the crazy things
about being up there is,
you know,
you read about it,
but you really can't rescue
somebody very easily up there.
I mean,
took to carry a human body
down into the rescue them is,
is nearly impossible.
And I kind of always thought in my mind,
you know,
if I saw somebody lying on the ground,
like I would,
you know,
some in the energy to pick them up.
And I was actually coming back from the
summit and I was on the South Summit,
so just below the [inaudible] art 28,000,
800 feet or something like that.
And this a Brazilian woman
who I'd met in base camp,
um,
named Tyce who I've become friends
with your in Nepal for a couple months,
you start talking to people,
getting friends with other climbers,
whatever.
And I see her lying on
the ground with her head,
like leaned back in her oxygen
mask off to the side and I'm like,
oh my God.
Like this is the moment
that I'm most feared.
Like somebody who I know is lying here
on the side of the mountain and I think
to myself,
I've got to pick her up.
I've got to pick her up and somehow like
carry her down this mountain and I lean
over to grab her and I try with all my
might to do anything and I realized I
can't move her six inches.
Like I'm completely exhausted.
Muscles aren't working.
Brain's not working.
So I do.
The only thing I can think to do is I
just wrapped her in my arms and I say Tice
like if you can hear me,
it's Collin,
you need to get up,
you need to get your oxygen mask on,
you need to start moving
like please get up,
please get up.
No response.
She was climbing with a Sherpa,
another guide right next
to her and they were like,
look like we're having
trouble with her oxygen mask,
but we're going to fix
it like it's coming.
All right.
And I was like just kind of going
through this intense moment,
like what do I do?
How can I help?
And it's as weird as,
you know,
I'm not proud of it necessary to say it,
but like there was nothing I could do.
Like it's just the most
helpless feeling in the world.
Where you want to help the common person,
you know,
a friend,
I mean this person had to be a friend,
but if any human being is lying
on the ground in the snow,
you're like,
I want to help this person
get down this mountain.
And I was just,
I'm so close to,
on my limit up there,
the summit,
there was nothing I could do.
Fortunately.
Um,
she was not one of the people
that passed away that day.
Her,
her team did get her oxygen mask on her
and she actually made it to the summit
and back down safely.
She went up,
she ended up going up from there,
which to me is like another quote,
crazy part of that story.
But it was an interesting
lesson for me in like,
you know,
you hear these stories,
you can't move bodies up there,
there's nothing you can do the rescue.
And people have been criticized for not
doing these crazy rescues when things
have gone wrong up there.
But it really hit home for me like how,
how hard it would be to move somebody
down that mountain from that altitude.
And so when you're up there,
you know,
unlike,
Antarctica,
I was actually alone in Everest.
Like I said,
it was pretty crowded day.
Like you're essentially alone up there.
Like if you can't putting one foot in
front of the other up in the death zone,
there's not,
not a whole lot that you can do.
Um,
so the three people that died up,
did they leave them there?
I'm not sure with those specific
people because sometimes they will,
you can get it like a large team of
people to slowly lower people down.
And you know,
in a weird way it's actually easier to
lower a dead body than it is to lower a
live person because a dead potty,
you don't have to worry about breaking
bones and things like that if you're
lowing someone over rocks
and things like that.
So I actually believe those
parties are no longer there,
but there are quite a few bodies,
you know,
still on the mountain in
particularly the north side,
the Chinese,
so you can climb it from two sides.
The Nepal side,
which is more commonly climb
where I climbed or the Tibet side,
the Tibet side is known for having a lot
more of the body is still actually on
the climbing route for sure.
So,
but for me on that,
I mean that day in a crazy way continues
on because I got back down to camp four
and I'm thinking I'm going to sleep
for the night rest and come back down.
The mountain usually takes a few
days to get back down the mountain.
At this point,
you know,
I've only got one more mountain to
climb to come finish my world record the
explorer's Grand Slam and I was
about two months ahead of schedule.
So if I had climbed Denali
in the next two months,
North America's tallest
mountain up in Alaska,
I was going to set this world,
this world record that I was.
And so I called back home
to Jenna and I was like,
I made it like I made it.
And uh,
earlier in the day when my
hands had gotten frozen,
I had actually had a heated boot warmers.
And so I turned the heat in,
my boot warmers up as hot as possible.
So I'm like,
if my hand is prospecting,
what could my feet look like?
So I took crank those
up as hot as possible.
And so Jen is like,
hey,
like how are you doing?
Like you all right.
We've heard some reports
over social media.
That's been a really hard day up there.
Like,
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm all right.
Like no frostbite,
no injuries.
Like I'm good.
And then I was like,
well actually,
um,
I,
uh,
I burned my feet and she's like,
oh,
frostbite.
Like how bad is it?
And I was like,
no,
not frostbite.
I actually burned too,
like silver dollar
circles in the bottom two,
both of my feet from turning
my boot warmers up too much.
And she's like,
wait,
let me get this straight.
Like,
you climb Everest,
you don't get frostbite,
but you burn yourself.
She was like,
you,
your feet fire,
like just a bad situation.
Um,
but then she goes on and she was like,
she literally said,
the next thing you said to me,
I will literally never forget in my life,
but she goes,
so,
um,
you're in your tent,
right?
You took your boots off and everything.
You're curled up in there.
I'm like,
yeah.
And she's like,
well,
uh,
I actually need you to
put your boots back on.
And I'm like,
excuse me?
Like I just like,
she was like,
yeah.
So we've been doing some calculating
back home and it just so happens that if
you can get to the summit
of Denali in the next,
uh,
week,
you can set,
not one but two world records.
And I was like,
well,
that sounds nice,
but like I'm on the summit of
below the summit of Everest,
how the hell is that going to work?
She's like,
okay,
put your boots back on down now,
climb all the way back to base camp.
There's no time for you to sleep.
But then in a helicopter is
going to take you to Katmandu.
No time for a hotel,
no time for a shower,
but an evening flights
going to take you to Dubai,
to Seattle to anchorage.
And instead of having three
weeks to climb Denali,
you'll have three days.
But if you can do all of that,
you'll set another world
record like ready go.
So I was in disbelief,
but,
uh,
knowing better than to disobey
not only my amazing wife,
but the planner and logistics expert
in running the backer and all of this,
I assure enough put my boots back on,
wipe the slate clean and found myself,
um,
you know,
just a hundred hours after
standing on the summit of Everest,
I found myself over in Alaska
trying to push up to the summit to,
uh,
to try to set the two world
records and not just the one.
Now,
what kind of recover does your body
need when you exert yourself like that?
Like,
yeah,
climbing Everest.
I would think that your body's must be
you to be in some kind of state of shock
or,
I mean completely.
There's,
there's some clips of me on Denali
and those next few days where I'm just
absolutely trashed,
like I'm like,
like barely eyes up.
I'm going to try to push for the summit.
I'm going to this.
The one benefit I would say there is one,
most of it's not a benefit,
but I'll,
I'll keep it in the positive.
The one benefit is usually in the high
altitude mountaineering you need to
climatize so your body creates more
red blood cells when you go up into the
thinner air to allow you to breathe
oxygen better at the higher altitudes.
A mountain like Denali normally takes
three weeks to climb because you're coming
from sea level and to
get up to 20,000 feet,
you can't just get dropped off there.
If you or I right now got dropped
off on the summit of Denali,
we would pass out in a matter of minutes.
Right?
But because I'm coming from
Everest at 29,000 feet,
it puts Denali into perspective,
not from a technical mountaineering
standpoint cause it's still very dangerous
and very challenging mountain and a lot
of ways a harder mountain to climb Mount
Everest technically,
but 20,000 feet,
my body can handle the rapidest sent a
little bit better if I can muster the
energy to do it.
The physiology of my body is actually in
a better place to climb higher faster,
if that makes sense.
No,
it does make sense.
But then so when you're,
when you're done with this,
what,
how long did it take you to just
feel like a normal person again?
Yeah,
so I was on Denali.
I ended up summiting in
in three days and setting.
So the explorer's Grand Slam was the seven
summits plus in north and South Pole.
But the second world record was just
the seven summits by themselves.
So even though I went to the polls,
I still set the speed record
for the seven summits as well.
So seven summits,
131 days and the explorer's Grand
Slam 139 and then I returned,
um,
to Alaska and then home to Portland.
And honestly it was a good six
months until I felt normal again.
It at least,
um,
and I'm,
I'm definitely,
like I said,
I'm only about five weeks out from
Antarctica at right now and I,
I haven't really taken a lot of rest
and recovery have been on the road,
still doing various things and uh,
you know,
I'm nowhere near recovery.
It's going to take a
long time to get back.
So these,
these exertions I love them.
I love pushing my body,
but you know,
the,
the cycle of high performance
is also knowing how to recover,
recover well,
good nutritional that
and it takes a long time.
That one took six months and I would
imagine this Antarctica recovery is going
to take a long time as well.
Now when you say it took six months or
are you monitoring your physiological
levels,
what are you monitoring and how do
you find out like where you're at?
Yeah.
So I started to do a lot of bloodwork.
Actually early on in my triathlon career.
I,
um,
you know,
actually early on in my professional
triathlon cry mentioned I moved to
Australia not long after,
you know,
turning pro and coming out
of the gate with this win.
And I had the opportunity to go train
with some of the best triathletes in the
world was actually,
you know,
a couple of world champion
is a group of 15 of us,
a couple of world champions,
so female Ironman,
world champion,
a couple of Olympic medalist,
I mean some of the top
people in the world.
And I'm just like up and
coming professional triathlete.
And I think it's so cool that I'm
like training with the best guys.
I mean,
you know,
it'd be like,
a guy that just gets into the UFC and
all of a sudden he's training with the,
you know,
the,
the top contenders,
the title guys.
And like I wanted to
really roll hard with them.
And so I was training super hard
to try to keep up with the guys,
the best guys.
And I had an amazing month and then I
completely fell apart because their level
of training,
we're true worldclass level and I'm
starting out was just too much for me.
And so when crashed my entire system,
my testosterone drops to that
level of a 90 year old man.
I mean,
I was like,
had no testosterone in
my body and you know,
went through some serious overtraining,
which as you know,
like it's,
that's no joke.
Um,
learn that lesson the hard way.
And that was one of the darkest
moments of my athletic career,
but it's also been a net
benefit for me as I've gone,
you know,
that was back in 2011 or whatever.
And these products,
these world record projects had
been in the last couple of years.
And so I learned from that,
you know,
taking it way too much and not learning
how to recover to implementing things in
my,
so your question about what did I monitor?
You know,
resting heart rate is one
that I monitored a lot.
Heart rate variability as well.
Um,
as well as certain blood levels,
of course around the
whole endocrine system,
the testosterone levels,
the,
you know,
different hormone levels
and things like that.
So coming back,
I do blood work ahead of time,
then come back just it with
standard process with the
nutrition company that had
all this blood work on me.
So when I left Antarctica
before flying home beef,
you know,
next place I had to go actually was
to New York to do the today show,
which was a whole weird thing after being
alone in Antarctica to have this type
of TV cameras your face,
that's a whole other like
weird twilight zone moment.
But before I even did that,
I flew to Charlotte where their nutrition
innovation center is and did all my
blood work.
And so we can have basically this
longitudinal study of my blood work to
understand it.
And so I monitor all of that and
figure out what I'm deficient in,
what I need,
where my heart rate's at.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
basically a lot of inflammation in my
body and needing to kind of rid my body of
that and fully recover.
So when you're coming back from
all these summits and all these,
this time at altitude,
what has actually happened to your body
that causes you to be really depleted
for six months?
Like what,
what's,
what's happening other than the
fact that you were at high altitude,
low oxygen,
like what's taking place?
So one of the things that happened to
high altitude that you don't really think
about too much,
which is your body's not getting,
so the air actually has just as much
oxygen in it as it does at sea level.
But the air is less dense.
So that means as you breathe in the air,
you're literally getting
less oxygen into your blood.
It's less dense,
it's less dense,
less nitrogen and the pressure changes,
right?
So at the high altitude is actually
the pressure that's changing.
It's not less oxygen,
there's just as much oxygen,
but in a less dense form.
So in the same volume of breath,
you're getting less actual
o two into your blood.
What you going to higher altitude,
I guess.
Uh,
carbon dioxide.
Is that right?
Yeah.
I'm not a doctor.
Like I said,
all I know is you're getting less oxygen.
You're getting less oxygen in your body.
So what ends up happening is your
muscles of course need oxygen to perform.
So normally if I'm in a,
you know,
when I'm in my most elite physical shape,
I have resting heart rate during
a professional triathlon career,
like 35 getting out of bed,
you know,
38 low enough that if you weren't a
professional athlete and you went to a
doctor with a heart rate at 35,
they'd be like,
oh my God,
like you're going to die.
There's something wrong with you.
But like that's also a key
marker of elite performance.
You know,
that of course.
Um,
but uh,
what happens is your body can't PR
your body's getting so little auction,
even as your blood is a climatizing,
you're sleeping with a resting
heart rate at altitude on Everest,
like 9,000 beats per minute.
So,
you know,
that's pretty elevated heart rate,
24 hours a day.
And for,
in my case,
for 139 days straight.
So essentially you're just your heart.
It's just like Cookeaqua even at rest.
And so what that does to
your body in terms of,
you know,
it throws your hormones around it.
Obviously you lose body weight,
body fat,
body composition changes,
all of those things
really shift and happen,
uh,
in a pretty intense way.
So coming back,
like actually just getting
your heart rate back down,
getting your,
you know,
a parasympathetic nervous system to just
relax and stress free and all that kind
of stuff.
It takes a while for sure.
So what do you do to help yourself
recover when you come back?
Cause there's specific kinds of food that
you eat or supplements that you take.
Um,
you know,
I'll start with a few different
things that I find to be the work.
Well,
one sleep.
I mean,
I think that sleep in our culture
in general is really underrated.
I think,
you know,
if you go in the corporate
world and everyone's like,
I pulled this all night or I work,
you know,
120 hours a week,
I this I that or whatever.
Like,
you know,
I'm telling you a story about pushing
through the night and going 32 hours
straight.
There was a time and a place
for big pushes without sleep.
But like we are not built to
do that sustainably in any way,
shape or form.
So in my training,
when I'm training for these things,
I prioritize sleep,
I prioritize taking a nap,
the same thing when I'm recovering.
So really making sure I get
that sleep is the most for me,
the most natural way to recover.
And top of that soft tissue work.
I'm a huge believer in massage
as well as chiropractor.
Uh,
I've been going to a chiropractor since
I was a little kid and to me that makes
a big difference just to
have everything in alignment,
everything kind of,
you know,
working well,
uh,
officially in my body.
Um,
and then,
yeah,
supplements,
you know,
definitely reducing inflammation.
So for me,
gut health is huge.
Um,
so getting those probiotics,
getting the right stuff in,
you know,
it's easy to have,
that leaky gut or things where
you're not getting nutrition,
observe,
absorbed properly.
And I think we all in various states,
you know,
you deal with that,
in the standard American Diet for sure.
We're leads to that for a lot of people.
Um,
so getting that nutrition clean and right.
so yeah,
sleep,
rest,
recovery,
nutrition.
Um,
and then,
you know,
I've definitely been taking,
taken a lot of supplements
through my life.
I err more towards the whole
food supplements these days,
but I find,
you know,
things like Tumeric that
really reduce inflammation.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
magnesium definitely helps a lot.
So there's a few things that I,
that I take daily,
but a really,
I think sleep and a clean
diet will goes a long way.
Um,
I,
you know,
mess with some cryo before.
I find that to be pretty,
pretty good.
I didn't do that a lot,
but I've done that in
the last couple of years,
a bit.
So various things.
Um,
but yeah,
for me,
sleep,
diet,
nutrition is the key to recovery.
And what kind of foods do you
do when you say eating clean?
Yeah,
a particular way of eating.
I'm uh,
I'm recently,
uh,
doing more of a pescatarian diet.
So I,
I've mostly cut out meat,
although that's very,
I was raised that way.
My parents have been vegetarians forever.
Um,
well I should say pescatarian,
so they,
they eat some fish.
Um,
but no,
you know,
no chicken,
no beef,
none of that.
Um,
for me,
I've actually,
even in Antarctica there was some,
uh,
in my freeze dried meals,
there was,
you know,
beef and chicken and stuff like that.
So it's not something I've out my dad
freeze dried meals as well as bringing
those column bars with the main thing.
But every dinner I had one freeze
tribe meal at the end of the day.
That was an extra thousand calories.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It was a company who was Al Pioneer,
but same thing as a
mountain house basically.
Um,
so it was rice noodles
mixed with chicken or beef.
But,
um,
when I say he can clean,
I mostly mean just like
eating a whole food stuff,
like not eating,
not eating processed crap,
refined sugars,
that kind of stuff.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm a normal human being,
so I'm guilty of that as anyone from time
to time of just grabbing the easiest,
closest thing.
Um,
but like I said,
my dad,
my dad's an organic farmer.
My mom,
my stepdad started a chain of natural
foods grocery stores when I was a kid.
So I was really raised around,
you know,
in the,
in a sort of hippie co op days
of the natural foods movement,
which of course now with Amazon owning
whole foods is to do a lot more to the
mainstream.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
that was what I was raised around and,
eating Keenwa Rice,
Kale,
you know,
that,
those kinds of things,
you know,
beans,
whole food nutrition is,
has gone a long way for me,
particularly when I need to recover.
Now.
Do you mess with CBD at all?
Um,
it's not something I've,
I've done a lot of,
uh,
I hear amazing things.
I've definitely not opposed to it at all.
Uh,
but I,
uh,
I haven't,
I haven't tried.
What's your experience been with that?
I've been experimented with it
for the last couple of years.
It has a pretty profound
effect on alleviating soreness,
especially joint soreness.
And it also makes you feel good though.
The word is that it alleviates anxiety,
which I don't suffer a lot of,
but it makes me feel relaxed.
Did you,
do you take it orally or
do you use it topically?
I take a look.
A dropper.
The dropper I'd take like
whatever they say to take.
I took like five times more than that.
Did you take it at night?
Like they're gonna take it during the
morning and I take it at night as well.
I just always feel like I'm
running my body at red line,
running my brain at red line so much.
So whatever they say you need,
I just double it for almost everything.
And do you feel like,
obviously it doesn't have
the THC effects of it,
but do you feel like in it,
no,
nothing.
You're not clear headed clear mind.
Yeah,
and my THC tolerance is
so high it doesn't really,
but some forms of it,
uh,
have a small amount of THC and I think
there may be some sort of synergistic
that that happens with the THC combined.
The CBD that helps people even
more because a lot of people,
uh,
that have pain,
particularly chronic pain,
they experience a lot of relief from THC
from just smoking or vaporizing it or
using edibles.
So I think that the,
uh,
the CBD with a little bit of
THC might have a better effect.
A lot of fighters say,
yeah,
sure.
No,
I'm,
I'm interested in trying the CVD for sure.
Something I should definitely try it.
Do you find that it gives
you like a sustained,
like as it relief when it's in your body,
like a masking relief or do you feel
like it actually is like curing the root
cause of that inflammation or anxiety?
It's masking it all.
I think it's alleviating the inflammation.
It's just,
it's a very healthy thing
for your body to eat.
It's,
well,
you know,
obviously,
uh,
there's a bunch of different oils
that will alleviate inflammation,
different essential fatty acids and
fish oils are very good for him.
Information,
I think anything that you can take that
helps your body mitigate inflammation.
Inflammation seems to be a
gigantic problem without,
with just not with pain just with paint.
But I think also with anxiety,
I think it's,
it's entirely possible that
feelings of discomfort,
you know,
like,
like when you,
when you see people that are anxious,
they're often look bloated.
To me,
they often look like,
I think it's just an
overall sense of unwellness,
you know?
And I think that poor diet exacerbates
that and a good diet can alleviate some
of those symptoms.
And I think that CBD
is a big part of that.
100%.
I mean,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm interested to try that for sure.
I've definitely that inflammation.
Even for me coming back from Antarctica
and this quarter of recovery phase.
What's weird is like you
saw how lean I got then,
but my body I think cause it was so
depleted of food source is now actually
almost trying to put fat back on my
body like of kind of storing that.
So actually my body comes to some,
feels weird to me right now because my
body is like just like trying to figure
out where the hell I'm at and I think
a lot of that comes from that chronic
inflammation and certainly just those
elevated cortisol levels of just being so
jacked up and red line like you said,
just like so wired because of finding
ways to kind of mitigate that I think is
crucial and I should try it.
What form would you
recommend trying that perform
like that?
I like to draw.
I like it because like
there's gel tabs are fine,
but I think it's unnecessary
about is absorbing that the coal,
the cover scope,
the stuff just go right to the oil.
I just think it's the best way to do it,
but I'm a,
I'm a big fan of curcumin
and Tumeric as well.
I think those are really good to try
and Ashwagandha or any of the like the
mushroom,
the mushroom teas and stuff like that.
This stuff actually
that I have right here,
that just wasn't a
plant while lion's mane,
mushroom elixir.
I love this stuff.
Yeah.
I take this,
uh,
all the time.
I make a tea out of this mess with like
the courthouse steps and the Ashwagandha
as well.
They kind of reduce some
of the good cortisol,
like emotional or hormonal
balances type of stuff.
Quarter sepsis.
Fantastic too.
For endurance to 100%.
Yeah,
we have a PR on it.
We have an audit product called shroom
tech sport that is core to subs,
a B vitamins and a bunch adaptogens.
It really
cool.
Really has a big impact on me in terms
of like how hard I can push in the gym.
I take it about an hour
or so before it out.
Yeah.
Let your body absorb it and it just,
it just really has a real effect.
It doesn't give me a jittery thing either.
Yeah.
It just gives me more energy.
Just kind of take it an hour before it
kind of primes your body for that more
oxygen uptake.
Is that Kinda the idea behind Cortis apps?
That's what I've been told anyway.
It came out of a high altitude herders.
They noticed that.
Yeah.
When there the cattle were
eating certain mushrooms,
they had more energy and so then they,
that's,
that's how they started
experimenting with this stuff.
They actually grow it on caterpillars.
What?
Yeah,
so strange man.
See if he can find it.
Cordyceps mushrooms grown on
caterpillar picturing like this room of
caterpillars with like carrying
around mushrooms on their back.
It's real freaky.
It's really freaky.
But apparently the way they farm it,
that's the way they farm it.
They actually grow it on Caterpillar.
That's fascinating.
Yeah.
Weird.
It's expensive shit,
but like there it is.
Oh Wow.
Look how fucking strange.
So those,
that the bottom there,
that's the caterpillars and the mushroom
growing out of their heads or something
like,
thank you.
I'll take that snip that
shit off the caterpillars.
Fucking weird man.
Yeah.
Well apparently it works well.
It does.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
there's so many bad at mean Paul Stamets
who's been on the podcast before and I
can't wait to get them back on again,
but he's a mycologist and it was one of
the best podcasts that I've ever done in
terms of like really explaining the
benefits of different fungi and different
mushrooms and how many
different nutritional benefits
you can derive from them.
I mean,
I,
I can't agree more just the,
the,
the whole food nutrition
from many different levels.
It's mushroom,
Tumeric,
this full plant derivatives.
I mean,
to me they go,
they go a long way in their pure form.
For sure.
Yeah.
What about what,
what do you drink?
Do you drink a lot of water?
Do you drink fruit juices,
vegetable juices?
Mostly,
mostly water.
To be perfectly honest,
um,
I,
I do usually start the day
with a smoothie of some kind.
So usually it's got,
it's got fruit in it.
Um,
obviously fruit.
And the other thing I put in there,
it's,
I've been using this stuff that it's
actually the company standard process is
just coming out with it,
but they,
let me try it ahead of time.
At Starbucks is slow release glucose
so it's a protein powder but instead of
giving to that glucose spike like you
would from a refined sugar or something
like that,
it's kind of a long
burn long-chain glucose.
Um,
I don't know the full chemistry of that,
but I find it makes a big
difference rather than kind
of just getting that sugar
spike early in the day.
It actually kind of gives
this slow release of energy.
And I was using that was actually
in the column bars as well.
And I really liked that particularly
for endurance because you know,
if you start like taking the goop
packets or something like that,
you get that spike of a hundred calories.
You get that like quick like boom,
burst of energy replies
replenished at your glucose stores.
But this I feel like
just as a much slower,
cleaner burn.
And it lasts a longer for technically,
you know,
for,
for anaerobic stuff.
I mean maybe you need kind
of that explosive power
or whatever,
you know,
different things for that.
But for some of the like
low heart rate zone one,
zone two like long grinding type of stuff
that I do in the mountains or pulling
the sled or whatever,
I find it's really good
for stuff like that.
Now what scares me about people
like you is how old are you now?
33.
You're very young.
I'll take that.
This is,
this is what I'm worried.
I'm worried that you've already done so
much crazy shit that you have to push
past the craziest shit you've already
done and you've already been on Everest.
It sounds like you were kind of
like you weren't on death's door,
but you open the front gate,
the front gate.
You were on the lawn.
Yeah.
You're on death's lawn.
Sure.
You know.
No,
absolutely.
I mean you never said that people
were literally died that day.
Um,
you know,
did he do to try to do next?
This is,
this is the question like,
yeah,
do you have some crazy shit
in your head right now?
And you're like,
okay,
now I'm going to the moon with a fucking,
you know,
it's bloody,
it's two fold.
It's an interesting intersection.
I appreciate that.
That you call me,
call me young.
I'll take that all day long,
but 51 so you are younger to me,
but I guess in terms of an athlete terms,
right?
You know,
you're in the,
you're in the Pete.
Yeah,
the peak for endurance athletes
and it's fun to be here.
But I also think it's a moment
in time where a little bit of,
a little bit,
I'll say I won't give
myself too much credit,
but a little bit of wisdom
meets also athletic performance.
A moment in time where
I've had enough experience,
enough setbacks,
ups and downs and success of course with
the world records and things I have,
but to really take stock
of what's important to me
and what I've realized more
and more is I'm super curious about
pushing the limits of my own potential
hundred percent we've talked about that.
I love that.
But I actually don't think of myself so
much as a risk taker or an adrenaline
junkie when say serious.
I'm not just bullshitting.
You're like,
I really,
when I think about it,
like these things are,
are really methodical.
There's sign out,
know their,
their practice,
they're there.
And it's not to say there's not risk.
You saw me trying to set up
my tent that tent flies away.
Like I'm screwed.
Like I'm in a bad way.
Um,
what would you do?
Would you run after it?
I mean,
you'd sell no chance of catching
up for that thing thing is gone.
Um,
yeah.
You,
you know,
you hit the,
you hit the ejector button on the call,
the plane of hope,
they can find your type of thing.
And even that's like in our storm,
like that unlikely they're
going to get there.
But for me,
what I'm honestly most excited about next,
um,
yes,
I have some other projects
that I'm marinating in my mind.
Do I have other expeditions?
Sure.
I haven't,
uh,
they're not fully crystallized
enough to announce right here,
unfortunately.
But,
um,
you know,
I've got some ideas but more
so like I'm excited about,
you know,
sharing what I've learned.
Like I said,
that wisdom meets high performance
of actually having an ability.
Now,
like I said,
when I started this,
I had,
you know,
my friends following me on Instagram and
I'm starting to have ability to share
this story.
People are asking for me to,
you know,
take interviews.
I'm,
I'm writing a book right now.
Lots of my learnings going into
that kind of stuff of really,
really having an ability to pass this on.
Because for me,
as fun as it is for me
to push my own limits,
like I,
what really inspires me.
What really fires me up is when,
when I get emails or
notes from people like,
hey man,
I watched across Antarctica.
I haven't been to the gym in five years.
And like I've gone every day since
then or I'm trail running now.
Or like I started that business,
I never said I was going
to star or whatever.
And so having an ability to have a moment
in time when I can share some of my
learnings.
You know,
with the world in meaningful
different contents.
That's,
that really excites me.
You know,
I love the opportunity to do that,
but man,
like for sure there's some other,
there's some other events
on the horizon as well,
but uh,
but yeah,
it's not just about one
upping the next thing.
I think that that's a,
a losing proposition in the long run
of always trying to do the bigger,
badder,
craziest thing.
Because when the stakes are,
like you said,
the razors line between life and death,
you keep one upping yourself enough.
You know,
you don't,
you don't make it to
the end of a long life,
unfortunately.
And I'm not trying to
have that be the end.
Well,
it sounds like,
I know you've already
broken world records.
You've,
you,
you're in this weird place where you've
accomplished so much that in order to
accomplish other things,
if you're going to take
it to the next level,
it really has to be
truly life threatening.
Do you have any recommendations?
Do you want to come on the next one will
say move into the next stage of life
that doesn't involve risky.
I don't know.
You seem like a nice guy.
I don't want anything to happen to you.
Okay.
Give me,
give me some wisdom.
You've got a couple of,
almost a couple of decades on me.
If you,
if you were whispering in the
ear of your 33 year old self,
how about this?
You know,
you've,
you've had an interesting path.
If you're whispering in
the ear of your 33 self,
what would be some advice that you would
give yourself that you'd be happy that
you lived out over the next 20 years?
Well,
I mean obviously life experience.
When you have life experience,
learn those lessons.
Become a better person,
be better at communicating,
be better at everything you do.
But the problem with what you're
doing and it's not a problem,
but in,
in this context,
is that you're pushing these incredible
endurance records in nature and
particularly in cold weather.
And this is what's stunning about these
things is that you're risking your life.
It's not that,
it's just difficult.
Like running in ultra marathon
is incredibly difficult,
right?
Sure.
But what you're doing is not
just incredibly difficult.
You're doing it in these incredibly
harsh environments and particularly in
Antarctica,
you don't have any relief.
There's nothing.
No one's going to help you.
Like you said,
your tent blows away.
You're like,
you might very well be fucked,
right.
You are right.
I don't know what you could do that
would one up that this is the problem is
like you're,
you're one up margin of error is
you're in this very strange sort of
stratosphere
yeah.
Of one attitude.
Maybe.
Maybe it's um,
you know,
we take a page out of the Bruce
Springsteen glory days song and just,
you know,
kick might kick my feet up and talk
about the glory days for the rest of the
time.
You don't have to do that.
But the thing is,
I mean,
don't listen to me,
man.
Do whatever you want to do.
Obviously you're going to,
you're not going to listen to me,
but you could do,
you hit apply this sort of mental
fortitude that you've demonstrated in this
ability to push the things you
could apply it to anything.
It doesn't have to.
This physical feats of risking death
and in frigid cold temperatures in the
middle of the fucking
nowhere are literally at the
bottom of the planet earth
that I know and,
and that's to me,
that's actually,
that's why it's exciting because for me,
yes.
Are there some other physical expression
that I want to have in the world?
For sure.
I know I have some ideas like I said,
but,
and it's not necessarily trying
to one up the next thing,
but it's also why it's exciting to me.
The lessons that I try to learn that
I try to share with other people,
like you said,
our universal lessons,
but they also,
if I referred them back to my own self
are also universal lessons in my own
life.
So like you said,
it's like,
hey,
like what's the next thing
I'm super passionate about?
If you,
I have the confidence to sit
with a white board with no money,
no resources,
no background,
and incredibly supportive fiance at the
time now wife who's like down to like
ride or die with me and
go into this with me like,
and we created what we did.
We did something that people
literally wrote about and said,
this is impossible.
People have died trying this.
You can't do this and we've achieved it.
It gives me confidence,
not that I can do some
other crazy physical thing,
but it gives me confidence like cool.
Like I want to start off,
I want to start a business
that makes millions of dollars,
like cool.
Like let's figure out how to do that.
Let's,
let's do the equivalent
of writing into Google.
What's the difference
between PR and marketing?
You know,
like let's do that.
So,
you know,
as I,
do a ton of public speaking
now write this book,
the things are things that I'm doing
that's super fun to share those with the
world.
So I'm having a lot of fun doing that
and actually sharing the universal truths
and the wisdom that I've learned that I
think can it be applied different ways.
But it also goes to now I get to have
the fun of applying those in all of those
other different ways of my life.
And so,
you know,
for me,
I think that the,
the,
the future is bright,
particularly if I don't,
I don't really think of myself as
this endemic core outdoor athlete.
It's very easy to put me in that box.
It's very easy to say like,
cool,
so you climb mountains,
you're a mountain climber
was like before years ago,
I had never really climbed mountains,
but I happen to do something about it.
So I've never been in the polar region.
That's why this British
guy was looking at me like,
oh,
Hahaha,
young boy,
I've spent all this time in an article.
You'll never survive this.
And like,
not only just survive it,
but like I finished first,
like I beat him,
but I'm not beat them
by two and a half days.
Um,
but like,
I'm not sitting here going like,
you know,
I'm fascinated by Antarctica.
What I like to go back someday.
Absolutely.
But I'm not like calling a
Brady the polar explorer only,
you know,
it's like,
what else can I explore
that actually presses me?
I mean,
I love to learn.
I love to learn about the mind,
explore that.
Um,
there's so many different
ways to express that,
that I'm just excited for what the future
holds in lots of different verticals.
Well,
listen,
I think you could fucking do anything.
I think it's very clear what
you've already accomplished.
You could literally do anything you want,
but I want to,
I want to see you live.
Yeah,
me too.
How about this?
How about you break some crazy endurance
running feats about that ultra marathon
because it feels a little bit safer.
The worst thing's going to happen
to you to get really fucking tired.
But
maybe,
maybe the next thing is,
I mean maybe I'm not the
funniest guy in the world.
What do you think about comedy?
I mean,
I know that's a big piece,
you know,
should I get back out there on the stage?
Listen,
if you can communicate and
you can make people laugh,
you can make a group of people laugh.
Could do stand up comedy.
It's just a matter of taking steps and
figuring it out and writing stuff out.
And I mean,
you've got all a lot of
fucking stories for sure.
No,
I mean just how about getting on stage
in front of people and telling people
that you're the first person that
cross and article on foot 52 days?
Like what in the fuck.
I do a lot of that.
I did enjoy that.
I love public speaking.
I do a lot of that.
Corporations,
kids,
everything.
That's too easy.
Well,
trust me,
I do it.
You could do that.
Yeah.
It's fun.
No,
I have to say I gotta give a shout out.
You definitely don't remember this,
but I actually have met you once before
about seven years ago in a tiny little
comedy club.
You did a bit out in Portland
of small little venue.
I'm sure you do way bigger
venues now called the helium.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's great.
And a,
at the time it was funny,
I was thinking about
when I was driving over,
I was like,
wow,
what's this bit?
And you were doing this bit about,
hey there Delilah.
Was that like a damn,
that's a long time ago.
Wow.
That's what I most remember it.
But the reason I was there actually was,
um,
when I first started
training for triathlon,
uh,
professionally,
I started training with
this guy named Phil Claude,
who was training a couple
of UFC fighters that time.
You remember Mike Pierce who
fought in this local guy,
poor guy as well.
And so I didn't know a lot about MMA.
I still certainly,
I'm not as well versed as you are,
but I got in this gym,
my coach was like,
Hey,
you're going to start
training with these MMA guys.
And I was like,
you know what,
like,
I'm a skinny little triathlete.
These guys are like,
you know,
brawlers but I was,
man,
what does I impressed?
Like talk about a
multisport true multisport,
right?
And all the different disciplines.
I don't have to tell you this obviously,
but I was blown away by
how strong the word became.
Good buddies.
And Mike said to me,
he was like,
hey man,
I'm going to this comedy show.
This guy named Joe Rogan is going
to be doing his comedy calm,
listen to him.
So,
uh,
you know,
you made me laugh back then.
So,
uh,
mad respect and uh,
yeah,
it was like,
it was a fun,
fun to see into that world a little bit.
Thanks man.
I guarantee you could do that,
but if you still want to do endurance
things like please do something where
you're not going to die.
That's all right.
You know,
I made it back.
You're safe at salad.
So yeah,
the goal,
I mean,
like I said,
the goal was not to
keep one upping myself.
I mean I think that's a
part of the danger of
this kind of endeavor.
You means you,
you really have one upped me.
You've done some crazy one up in man.
Sure.
Like I said,
I think that it,
if,
if I only thought of myself
as a professional athlete
and that was my identity
was tied up in that,
I think we see that across the spectrum
of professional athletes in general,
um,
of people just going,
hey,
I'm a pro athlete and the second I'm not,
even if they banked millions of dollars
as an NBA player or something like that,
their whole identity disappears
with the feet of athleticism.
I read a really interesting article
today that I was really compelled by
actually,
which was a story about Kevin Duran
that was on espn.com this morning.
And it's about him and his business
manager and a couple other guys that have
kind of gotten around him and like,
dude,
you're like one of the best
basketball players in the world,
MVP.
But he's already thinking about all the
various things that he's doing in his
life.
And what I loved about that
article was they were like,
you know,
sports center back in
the day used to be guys,
you know,
hitting home runs,
dunking basketballs,
which of course it still is that.
But they'll intersperse that with like,
Kevin Durant just made a,
you know,
venture investment in this company,
or like they're growing this watermelon
water brand or they're this or that.
And so I think sports,
particularly with the
growth of social media,
with storytime,
with media,
with content,
with all the other ways
we can share the insights,
which isn't just the game,
which isn't just me and
the arena pulling the sled,
but it's actually a way
to connect with people.
Whether that's in the sense of Kevin
Durant making incredible venture
investments in companies or that's with
storytelling that actually reaches,
you know,
universal truth with people.
You know,
I've got a single mother from Nebraska
reaching out to me and saying like,
Hey,
I don't care about
mountains or the outdoors,
but like I'm going through some hard
stuff like in the middle of the country.
Being a single mother in
your story connects with me.
Thank you for giving me the
inspiration to keep pushing forward.
So for me it extends beyond just this
athlete in this arena because we have all
these other ways to storytell
to create content to you know,
and be involved in businesses
and things like that.
So that's where my mind's at next.
It hasn't fully crystallized
into the most concrete of plans,
but the ability to explore all these
different mediums and just having sort of
the sports be the catalyst for growth in
that way is what I'm really passionate
about.
Well that's awesome man.
And whatever your plans are
of 100% confidence in you,
you're an inspiration man.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
Thanks brother.
Really appreciate you,
man,
and tell everybody your Instagram how
to get ahold of you on social media.
Yeah,
fall along.
It's just my name at Collin Brady.
I'm also,
my website is just my name,
[inaudible] dot com got a list on there.
Like I said,
I'm working on a book.
There's lots of juicy details
that I haven't shared yet,
so if you're interested in that,
you know,
pop your email address in there.
We'll keep you posted when
that comes out next year,
but at colony or Brady,
or calling a [inaudible] dot com come,
come say hi.
Beautiful.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Okay.